hello everyone welcome to the june 2021
aspie anything edition of the mindscape
podcast
i'm your host sean carroll so this is
the uh
coming out of pandemic time period that
we're in right now
hope people are getting vaccinated being
able to resume their lives again a
little bit
jennifer and i both fully vaccinated uh
slowly starting to do things
that we weren't doing before you know
before you could go to some restaurants
at least here in l.a i don't know what
it was like different parts of the world
some restaurants if they had open
outside seating then
there was a little bit where you could
go but now we're able to go to some of
our old
favorite restaurants that are reopening
again we even went to a movie
in a movie theater we have not yet
gotten on a plane i know that some
people were getting on planes of course
all along trying to take precautions but
we didn't have any strong needs
uh to go anywhere so we haven't been on
a plane in over a year
i don't have a plane trip planned until
i think july or something like that
maybe august
so uh that'll be something i hope i can
remember everything i did notice that my
passport
had expired so i got to get that fixed
all of the crap
that is involved with coming back to the
real world overall it's very much worth
it but woof
there's a lot of stuff you got to get
done um
other than that yeah no news from around
here really i'm
uh looking forward to answering these
questions we got a lot of questions
uh as you know as if you're veterans
then
we get questions from people on patreon
who support the mindscape podcast with a
pittance each week
and they're the ones who are allowed to
ask questions in the old days when we
were a small elite group
i would answer every single question but
it became too big for that
so we have a new system now where i pick
questions to answer and group ones
together if they're similar thematically
once again this month there were far too
many good questions for me to answer so
if i don't answer your question
it's because i don't have anything
interesting to say about that like
you're very welcome to ask questions of
the form
did you read this book and what did you
think about it but if i didn't read the
book
i'm not going to answer the question i'm
just going to leave that out deleted so
it's not you
it's me if i'm not answering your
question but if you're listening
to these questions being answered and
you're burning up with jealousy
saying boy i wish i could ask a question
and have that be answered
you can support mindscape on patreon go
to patreon.com
sean m carroll a dollar a week something
like that would be more than enough
to let you be part of this community you
get ad-free versions of the podcast plus
you can ask ama questions
let's get to answering them let's go
[Music]
reiner gluga asks a priority question so
remember the other rule for patreons
asking questions is
if there's some question that is really
important to you you don't want it to
get left out because i don't pick it to
answer
the questions that month then you just
label it priority question
and i promise to answer it but you're
only allowed to do that once in your
life
so make it good when you ask a priority
question so reiner says
can you please explain what happens to
photons that don't arrive anywhere due
to the cosmic expansion i understand
that the light wave gets red-shifted but
is there a limit
so no there is no limit the universe
keeps expanding
photons keep getting red-shifted now i
do have to be a little bit careful
depending on how technical you want to
be here
what do you mean by redshifted okay when
you
emit a photon it has a certain
wavelength
in the rest frame of whatever emitted it
right whatever atom or galaxy or
whatever emitted the photon
you can talk about what the frequency
was or the wavelength with respect to
that emitter because that defines a rest
frame
in another rest frame with respect to
something that is moving rapidly with
respect to the emitter
the wavelength will look different right
so keep that in mind
when you absorb the photon you also have
to take into account
the rest frame of whatever is doing the
absorbing otherwise there'll be a blue
shift or a redshift
just from the doppler effect so
cosmologically
we can always talk in a somewhat
sensible way
about the redshift because there is a
rest frame
because there is basically a common rest
frame of all the galaxies
and all the stuff in the universe they
move at a few hundred kilometers per
second with respect to each other
but that's nothing compared to the speed
of light so for all intents and purposes
it's a common rest frame
so when you say the photon gets
red-shifted you have to tell me what
rest frame you're talking about once the
universe is
empty and there's nothing in it anymore
who's to say
what is the right rest frame to use to
measure it but if you just insist on
somehow continuing the
rest frame that we have now defined by
all the matter in the universe
into the cosmological future with
respect to that frame
a photon according to all the equations
that we know about now
will just get redshifted forever there's
no limit at all
oh so now i have two questions remember
i'm grouping questions together that i
think are
at least connected not necessarily the
same but there's a thematic similarity
so perry romanowski says i posted this
last month and while it was listed in
the questions answered it was not
answered so i post it again
so my apologies for this perry i clearly
remember answering your question i'm not
quite sure what happened it must have
been
uh mistakenly cut out when i was editing
or something like that but anyway
the irony being the question is about
editing and the question is
if you said something on a previous
podcast or video that you no longer
agree with
discovered it was wrong or insensitive
do you edit the old content or do you
simply correct the record
from now and going forward and the
related question is from
piatrek ziddle who says uh
have you ever recorded a podcast episode
and decided not to publish it
or maybe you were requested asked by
your guest to not publish it in what
circumstances would you make
such a decision so both these questions
clearly have to do with you know
ex-post-facto editing
of podcasts so i think i don't have a
policy about this it hasn't really come
up enough times for me to think
through all the possible ways this could
happen
um if i said something that was wrong i
wouldn't correct it i might you know
leave a note
in the comments or something like that
but i'm not going to go back and edit
the audio file i mean by the way
editing is very hard for audio podcasts
not just the physical editing of going
into
audacity which is the program i use to
do it but then you have to re-upload
i put all the podcasts on youtube even
though they're audio only some people
prefer
listening on youtube youtube simply will
not let you
edit or replace a file at all the main
podcast files can be replaced but it's a
little bit of a pain so the default is
just to keep it there
maybe flag something if i think it was
wrong certainly if i've changed my mind
about something
i'm not going to go back and edit the
podcasts that's that sounds like work
you know it's
like writing a book when you write a
book and you change your mind afterward
you write another book or you write an
article or something like that you
don't go back and correct all the books
now if something was
insensitive if something was you know
truly like out of bounds and insulting
or offensive
um that either i said or a guest said uh
i don't know i don't know i've never
come across that particular um
problem before i might in that case
because that reflects badly on the rest
of the world not just me if i'm
hurting the feelings of other people not
just making myself look dumb
then i might think about you know going
back and editing and leaving a flag up
there i mean i wouldn't
sneakily edit it if i do ever edit or
replace
an old podcast i would certainly want to
do so with full transparency
um to the question of have i ever not
published a podcast
no i have not ever done that i mean i it
would be hard
i was gonna say it'd be hard for me to
imagine doing that but i guess it's not
hard to imagine if someone came on
who was truly obnoxious and you know
violated the spirit of the podcast then
maybe i just would not
go ahead and not publish it but i'm the
one who is inviting people on so i try
not to invite
people like that you know many of the
people i invite on i haven't really
interacted
with before so it's always possible
if people didn't want their conversation
published after we had recorded it but
before i had posted it
then i would not post it i'm not going
to force people to
you know put up something that they said
if even if they don't want it said
before in fact you know
that's a very general rule i'm not
there's no gotchas here on the mindscape
podcast i want
people to be happy with what they said
so some people said something and want
to like
correct it or just delete a little bit
that has happened people have said oh
you know i said this thing i realized
now i was wrong
could you edit that out before you post
the episode then i will do and i that i
have done like
literally only once or twice in 150
episodes but um
willing to do that yes okay two more
questions that are being grouped
together
they're about ufos ben turner asks
actually they're about
bayesian analysis and ufos so that's the
best
ben turner asks a priority question can
you please help me frame
how to be a good bayesian with respect
to the credences i assign
to the possible explanations to the
navy's ufo reports
and someone labeled naive bayesian says
taking a bayesian approach how would you
decide between ufos being aliens and
ufos not being aliens
what is the bare minimum evidence you
would require to change your mind a blog
post grainy videos what would it have to
be
so um to the first question the being a
good bayesian you know
being a good bayesian means you have
some priors some prior credences before
any new data comes in
and then you update them when new data
comes in so
a lot a huge amount of the difference
between
perfectly sensible people about the
whole ufo issue comes into the priors
and bayesian analysis does not tell you
how to make
the right priors even if there is such a
thing
people have tried very hard to come up
with uh what it might mean to have the
right priors in a very general sense but
no one agrees about that as far as i can
tell so
what is your prior that there are
intelligent
technologically advanced civilizations
on other planets that send rockets to
buzz us
right send some sort of vehicles to fly
around in our atmospheres
you know my prior for that is very small
and that's where almost all
of the leverage comes from for me the
other part is the likelihood function so
given a certain theory uh how likely is
it that you would see this data
and here all good bayesians should agree
it's not like the priors everyone as i
said before
as i said in a book once your everyone
is entitled to their own
likelihood sorry to their own priors but
not to their own likelihoods the
likelihood of the data
given the theory so if your theory is
not specifically
there are aliens that are flying around
in ufos but your theory is just
there are technologically advanced
aliens that's theory number one
theory number two is there are not okay
so those are the two theories we're
trying to compare
what is the probability that even if
there were not
super advanced aliens visiting us here
on earth
that nevertheless there would be reports
of
fuzzy objects that we see with our eyes
or with our instruments and can't
explain
to me the probability of that is just
about one of course that's going to
happen you know of course there's always
things just at the edge of what we can
see they're not very clear
and our imaginations run wild so the
data that has
another fuzzy picture or another fuzzy
video of something
does not move me very much at all uh
plus the fact that
you know that that is that is i think
it's something that everyone
should have um the difference in priors
comes from the fact that to me
it is entirely implausible that if there
were intelligent aliens
they would fly all the way here to visit
us here on earth
okay so number one that's that's already
a lot like how did they know that we
were just becoming technologically
advanced right now
number two they would buzz us in the
atmosphere in small spaceships
that tried in some sense to remain
hidden from us
but failed right so they have enough
technology
to fly interstellar distances to zoom
around
stay mostly hidden from us but not
advanced technology enough to stay
completely hidden from us or not enough
common sense to do that
that just makes absolutely no sense to
me that is a completely
uh crazy theory in my mind so i don't
give it zero credence but i give it very
very small credence whereas
people over interpreting grainy
photographs and videos that i give very
very high credence to
so to naive bayesian's questions what
would it take to change my mind
you know i mean let me let me sort of
re-answer the previous question
as a way of answering this one to me
it's very much like evidence for the
existence of god
right uh there are things that religious
believers take as evidence for the
existence of god
in my mind if i try to be a good
bayesian say
what would the evidence be if god really
exists
if there existed an omnipotent being
that really
cared about us omnibenevolent loving
human beings
that would be very very very obvious in
my mind
god would not be hiding god would not be
difficult to discern
god would not allow people to fight and
kill in his name
and misunderstand what he said it'd be
absolutely trivial for
god to make himself perfectly 100
manifest right
you can always after the fact come up
with
justifications for why god doesn't do
that but that's not what a good bayesian
does
the good bayesian is supposed to say
ahead of time what would your
expectations be
and update on the basis of the data
there so you can always come up
after the fact with reasons why aliens
might come around and visit us
but remain hidden but fail to remain
perfectly hidden
but it's not at all what i would expect
the evidence that i would expect if it
were really true we the aliens would
just come down and say hi
or they would remain hidden those are
the two obvious things this weird
in-between thing
is extremely unlikely so the minimum
evidence that required to change my mind
um i don't i'm not sure what the
absolute minimum would be the number
that no amount of grainy videos will do
it let's put it that way
i think something much more direct
something that cannot be
easily explained away i mean by the way
if you're into this thing
just go on youtube and look for people
who've done a really
thorough job in explaining how all of
these videos can be very very easily
explained without
using any aliens or or um
super high-tech things whatsoever okay i
mean there's much more down-to-earth
explanations for this stuff
dan o'neil says are there major
discoveries that you think would have
been made by the superconducting super
collider that are beyond the powers of
the large hadron collider what
justification might be offered now for
building a collider more powerful than
the lhc
so the superconducting supercollider
which was cancelled back in the 90s
would have been higher energy and and i
think also higher luminosity
than the large hadron collider i'm not
sure about the luminosity thing
luminosity is how many collisions per
second but it certainly would have been
higher energy so energy is everything
when you do
this kind of particle physics at
colliders because e
equals m c squared and you want to make
high mass particles
you need to have a lot of e so you can
get a lot of m and
uh so therefore it's absolutely
plausible
that there are many many particles that
the ssc would have
found that the lhc is not just because
the lhc doesn't quite have enough energy
to get there
now it's also absolutely plausible there
are none right there's basically a range
of energies that the ssc
could have explored that the lhc has a
lot of trouble exploring and maybe
there's a lot of particles there
maybe there aren't that's the difficulty
we don't know ahead of time what the
answer to
an experimental test is going to be
because we haven't done the experiment
yet
that's why people are really really
invested in these precision measurements
like the muon
experiments that we talked about uh in a
previous podcast because
even if you uh are able to find
something in one of these precision
experiments
you generally only measure one number
you don't know exactly what is the
underlying mechanism that is creating it
to really understand what's giving you
that number
you need to build a bigger particle
accelerator so if these muon experiments
that seem to indicate maybe
tentatively possibly new physics beyond
the standard model
are verified and turn out to be correct
that would be very strong motivation for
building a collider more powerful than
the lhc
kathy seeger says what are your favorite
places on earth and where would you like
to travel to in the universe if you'd
had an interstellar spaceship at hand
i think these are two separate questions
kathy i should
there's there is a limit in the rules
that you're only supposed to ask one
question but somehow
i forgot to edit this and i just asked
them both out loud so let me give you
a stab um you know i
the favorite places on earth question is
a weird one actually i mean it's a very
it's a very obvious
uh natural question to ask but
it sort of assumes that there's a place
you'd rather be than any other place and
i actually
like being in different places at
different times you know what i mean so
i can i love going to paris for example
or to florence or to hong kong or to las
vegas
uh various places around the world um
new york city
boston san francisco you know i'm a big
city guy
more than a out in the country guy
but i'm very glad that i don't have to
get stuck in any one of those
places so you know i like the big cities
the excitement the experiences the idea
that you can uh each night when you
spend a week in a place you can go to a
different kind of experience
every night whether it's food or
entertainment or or just hanging out
with friends or something like that
those are my favorite kinds of places
um if i were able to travel anywhere in
the universe
you know the universe is mostly
dangerous and boring right most places
in the universe and the least
boring places or the most dangerous ones
it'd be fun to
visit you know near a black hole and
measure the gravitational field and
understand whether or not einstein's
theory of general relativity was correct
okay
that's something i would like to do but
i would worry about miscalibrating and
falling in
or finding myself in the middle of an
accretion disk or something like that so
if i had enough knowledge to be safe
about it i would like to visit close to
a black hole and be equipped to do some
experiments
david silbert says my question concerns
probability in ever ready in universe
you address this in the big picture but
mainly from the perspective of how we
should think about probability
if many worlds is true whereas to me
probability is a major
issue that many worlds needs to explain
in particular if a measurement has say
two possible outcomes why don't we
always observe them as being equally
probable
so i almost didn't answer this question
because i've answered many times
there's a blog post that i've written
that you can google called you know
why probability exists in quantum
mechanics or something like that or why
probability is given by the wave
function squared something like that
where i try to answer exactly this
question
um you mentioned the big picture now
maybe that was a typo and you meant to
say something deeply hidden which is my
book about quantum mechanics
but if not if you really meant the big
picture then
certainly you should read something
deeply hidden because that's where i
explained this in
in detail so i'm not going to rehearse
every single answer that i have but let
me just give you
my one favorite short answer to this
which is that it can't possibly make
sense
to give equal probability to getting any
experimental outcome when there are only
two experimental outcomes
because of what is called i think david
wallace labeled it diaconic
inconsistency
so which means that it's not consistent
over time
right so if i have two spins and
apologies for those of you who've heard
me give this example before
but if i have start with one spin i have
one spin
that is in pointing the x direction
which means that it is a 50 50 chance
that if i measure to be spin up or spin
down
i will get spin up or spin down right
or at least i can get either one let's
not presume the probabilities ahead of
time
if it's a spin x plus x and i measure it
along the z
axis i could get either spin up or spin
down so i'm going to agree ahead of time
that i'm going to do that i'm going to
measure that spin and if i get
spin down i'm going to get another spin
which is also in the x direction i'm
going to measure it again
okay if i get spin up for the first spin
i won't
so i measure only one spin if i get spin
up the first time and i measure two
spins if i get spin
up spin down the first time what that
means is
after measuring the first spin i have
measured one spin and there's two
possible outcomes it was spin up
or spin down right so 50 50 chance of
getting either one
according to this rule but now
i measure two spins on the down branch
right i say well
if i measured spin down i measure the
spin again and i get either up or down
for the new spin
so now there's three outcomes there was
either just spin up
or there was spin down and spin up or
spin down and spin down because i
measure two spins if i measure down
initially
so if i did those right one after the
other i would say i get
three answers and i should give them all
equal probability one third one third
one third
okay that's clearly doesn't work right
because
why is it that the probability you
assign to getting spin up
changes just because you're measuring a
different spin on an entirely different
branch of the wave function
it turns out that the only assignment of
probabilities
that is consistent diachronically that
does not change
if you fiddle around with different
kinds of experimental
apparatuses is the born rule is that the
probabilities given by the wave function
squared
that doesn't mean it is the it's right
but it's the only one that doesn't have
that problem so
you judge about whether it's the right
one or not
jesse rimler says i recently watched a q
a with noam chomsky where he was asked
to comment on the hard problem of
consciousness here's my summary of his
response
in the 17th century the hard problem was
motion the great thinkers of the time
assumed the universe itself was
mechanical
newton unintentionally showed that this
model was hopeless his theory crucially
involved forces that cannot be captured
within the mechanical philosophy
mechanical in this sense is sort of
you can directly see the gear wheels
this is me sean interpolating into the
question but
uh rather than just saying this happens
you actually provide a physical
mechanism of things touching each other
to explain why it happens
okay so back to jesse's question
newton's explanation was mathematical
but newton didn't believe it was an
actual explanation what newton showed
this is we're still paraphrasing chomsky
what newton showed is that we can
understand a theory but not what it
means thus the question of motion was
abandoned
and science reduced its goals to finding
intelligible theories
this was the correct thing to do and now
the same should be done for
consciousness we can find out more about
it
and develop theories but we should
abandon the idea of solving this current
hard problem
my question says jesse is chomsky's
description of the history of science
eccentric or
does this square with your understanding
and do you agree with the understanding
of the of abandoning the hard problem of
consciousness
um yeah i would change the wording
around in very minor ways but mostly i
think i completely agree
with what chomsky is saying here um
you know that i'm not quite sure i would
go along with the idea that newton's
theories were not an
actual explanation newton's theories fit
the data
but they did not provide you this
mechanical
insight uh in particular because there's
action at a distance right
the gravitational pull on the earth from
the sun or something like that is just
assumed to exist and be instantaneous
there's nothing
connecting the sun and the earth in this
particular
view what i would say is not that that
doesn't count as an actual explanation
but it doesn't count as the particular
type of explanation that you were hoping
for
in terms of some mechanical gear wheels
or whatever
so i wouldn't say that it's not an
explanation just not the kind
that you were hoping for ahead of time
and i do think that
that is something that scientists have
to be open-minded about
that when you ask well why is this true
you always have to be
open to the possibility the answer is
well is just like that
there's no special kind of mechanism
that fills your pre-existing idea of
what would count as a solution to the
problem
and that's exactly what i think is going
on with the hard problem of
consciousness
i don't think that there will be a
breakthrough where we say oh yes
now we've solved the hard problem i
think that so the hard problem
consciousness sorry for those who don't
know
rather than the easy problems of
consciousness how do we see things how
do we process information
how to react in the world david chalmers
has isolated the hard problem as
the first person experience why do i
have the feeling that it is like a
certain experience to you know see the
color of red or taste a certain color or
something like that the
intrinsically subjective first-person
part of conscious experience
explaining that is the hard problem and
the the claim in certain circles is that
it can't be done with a purely physical
view of the world and i think it's just
going to be wrong i think it's going to
evaporate
it's not that there'll be a breakthrough
where we say now this is the answer it's
just that we get better and better at
understanding what happens
in the brain and in human behavior and
in human thought
and we say that's it that's what
consciousness is it's all that stuff
happening
so that is the extent to which i agree
here on chomsky i think that with
chomsky i think that the hard problem
will evaporate
rather than being uh explained by some
brilliant insight
joy kolbek says what is chirality
chirality is just handedness handedness
in the sense of right-handed versus
left-handed you know if you
hold up your hands in front of you so
your thumbs are pointing up
the fingers on your right hand are
moving in one direction
if you if if instead of up you point
your finger
your thumb at yourself the fingers in
your right hand are pointing
counterclockwise
the fingers on your left hand are
pointing clockwise right so that's
that difference between right-handed and
left-handed that's what chirality is
it applies in particle physics because
there are particles
especially it makes a lot more sense
when you talk about massless particles
so that
you have particles moving at the speed
of light all the time right
so if a particle moves at the speed of
light you cannot go into its rest frame
it is always moving at the speed of
light and so there is always a
well-defined notion of
the direction in which it's moving count
that
count the momentum of the particle as
like your thumb
and then the particle can be rotating it
can be rotating in around that axis
either clockwise or counterclockwise so
there are left-handed particles and
right-handed particles
that's what chirality is the the fact
that there can be both left-handed and
right-handed particles
and there's the additional interesting
fact that in the standard model of
particle physics
these particles interact differently uh
the
su-2 part of the weak interactions
interacts with a left-handed part of
particles not with the right-handed part
that's a fact about nature that is kind
of interesting
joe lertola says i believe you said in
your book something deeply hidden that
there is a certain weight
that's divided between the branches of
the many worlds you said the branching
would not continue forever
i found this quite surprising how do you
know this um
well i don't know it so i'm sure i
didn't say that it would not continue
forever
it might not continue forever so you
know the branching that is going on and
i mean
let me back up here a little bit um
because this is going to come up later
in the ama there's a
very common feature when you try to
explain physics using words
but not equations that you're doing your
best to translate
very particular specific rigorous
equations into pre-existing
english language vocabulary okay and so
when you talk about branching and
splitting and all this stuff
it's a close approximation to what
happens but what we mean
is very specific and definite it has to
do with decoherence
and entanglement and the environment and
all these extra things that you don't
necessarily
keep in your intuitive picture when you
talk about branching
but the point is that it's possible i
even think it's likely
that a region of space corresponds in
quantum mechanics to a
finite dimensional hilbert space that is
to say
their only finite number of independent
completely orthogonal quantum states
that could possibly
say or describe what is happening in
this region of space
and you can take that region of space to
be our whole observable universe right
tens of billions of light years across a
finite dimensional hilbert space
it's still a big number the finite
dimension is still like 10 to the 10 to
122 or some big number like that
but it's still finite so if branching
happens all the time which it does
um then it can't happen forever because
there's only a finite number of branches
you could possibly fit
into hilbert's space what this actually
corresponds to
dynamically is all of the branches begin
to look alike and that's
true because the universe expands it
empties out
every single branch of the wave function
begins to look like
empty space with nothing in it that's
the highest entropy state
and it's a state where all the branches
look alike which means
that it doesn't make much sense to talk
about them as separate branches
anymore okay so it's not that there is
like
a cessation of the evolution of the
universe
it's just there's an equilibration it's
like the ice cube melting into a glass
of water
at some point it melts all the way and
then it doesn't melt anymore it's done
all the melting it's going to do that
doesn't mean the glass of water
disappears into the void
it still exists likewise the universe
and the wave function of the universe
will still exist but there's just not
going to be
anywhere more for it to evolve into a
higher entropy state anymore
alan white says alice has an electron i
sure hope that this is the drummer for
yes that is asking these questions
alan white says alice has an electron
when she measures the spin
the universe splits bob has an electron
that is entangled with alice's so she
immediately knows its spin as well
bob is far away so he will have to wait
a long time to learn
alice's result or he can measure his own
spin
however if he measures the spin the wave
function does not split
i find this very confusing perhaps
because i'm expressing it in words
rather than mathematically see i told
you
the whole words versus math thing would
come back up um
so again i've said this before but i'll
try to say it again
because not everyone hears everything i
say for some reason or another and also
because
saying things slightly different ways is
sometimes helpful um
the idea of taking the wave function of
the universe
and describing it as a set of branches
is
very very convenient it is a useful
thing for we human beings to do
because what we label as different
branches don't interact with each other
they act like they're independent
separate worlds thus the many worlds
interpretation
but the universe is the set of all of
the branches
okay and so you need to ask the question
what is the best way of taking the
universe the whole wave function
and dividing it up into branches and
it's not obvious that there's a right
way or a wrong way so
in my view it's up to you whether you
say that when
alice measures her spin bob the wave
function of the universe
instantly splits everywhere including
where bob is
or you have some patchwork quilt of
branches which says that in
alice's future light cone the wave
function of the universe branches
but outside it doesn't so in that view
bob doesn't split
until alice's light cone begins to
intercept him
so what this means for bob is
let's take the first point of view let's
say that when alice measures her spin
the whole universe instantly
simultaneously splits
in some reference frame and you can pick
what reference name it is it doesn't
matter for any possible observational
outcome
so now there are two copies of bob right
it's not there is
bob with one spin there is a version of
bob
on the branch where alice measured spin
up and a version of bob on the
ver on the branch where alice measured
spin down okay
so as you say when bob then measures the
spin the wave function doesn't split
that's true
because it's already split right there
are two different bobs they're both
measuring a spin with which is
guaranteed in each case
to give them a definite outcome so there
you go
in the other point of view where the
spin or the branching happens
with the speed of light but no faster
rather than simultaneously
then when alice and bob measure their
respective spins
splitting does happen in both cases but
the
different branches get knitted together
when their light cones begin to overlap
in such a way that where alice measured
up bob measured down and vice versa so
it all works out
but there's a little bit of
arbitrariness here and how we divide up
the universe into branches
volero says is there anything you had
believed in but completely changed your
view on
i should have grouped this with a later
question but that's okay um you know
yeah sure i mean obviously like i used
to be very young
i used to be a kid and i believed all
sorts of crazy things i believed in
psychic powers at one point in my
life as a child um in university
i believed that you could uh
develop rigorous scientific notions of
morality
and ethics based on nothing but science
i completely changed my mind on that
um you know in more late in life terms
you know i
believe that the cosmos constant was
zero pretty strongly
right um but my belief in that went away
because we had data that that uh really
changed his mind
in more personal ways i believed that
there was really really interesting and
important to think about
all the different ways that the
accelerating universe would be caused by
something other than
a cosmological constant uh or so
dynamical dark energy or uh modifying
gravity to get rid of
dark matter or dark energy but you know
in
working on those ideas over and over
again as a theorist and then in
watching the data come in again and
again favoring
the good old-fashioned ideas you know i
thought i didn't i'm not sure that those
ideas are wrong
but they're less urgent to me they seem
like less likely to lead to a
breakthrough so i changed my view on
that
so yeah you know i changed my view about
all these things uh i've changed my view
about the importance of
the budget deficit i used to really be
thinking that the federal government
should always
balance the budget every single year but
i know better than that now i think it
was a very naive economic point of view
not to say that you should let the
budget deficit grow without any bound
whatsoever
but it's very natural to have a deficit
to have a small amount of inflation
to let that uh encourage growth etc you
know pay back some of the debt when the
economy is growing
there's a whole much more sophisticated
view that people should have and that i
that i had than what i had is what i'm
trying to say
gillis 15 says i live in denver but i'm
now a native new mexican so i'm curious
about how you ended up being an external
professor at the santa fe institute
and have you visited the los alamos
national lab
and regarding new mexican food red or
green so those of you who've been to new
mexico know
the state official question is red or
green and it corresponds to the color of
chili that you want on your
food when you're eating it do you get
red chili or green chili i'm definitely
a red chili guy that's a very easy
question sometimes i'll
feel adventurous and go for the
christmas option which is half red and
half green but i can't imagine just
uh straight green unless it was a very
specific dish that called exactly for
that
um i've not visited los alamos no i
don't at least i don't think so
certainly not for many many years i
don't think i ever have i'm pretty sure
um for santa fe you know i it was always
a natural
fit for me but one that never just quite
came to fruition you know back when i
was in
graduate school uh it was i think that
was when
sfi was founded or at least it was
founded not
long before i entered graduate school
and you know i had
on the bookshelf that i was gradually
accumulating
these big red volumes of conference
proceedings from
conferences at santa fe about quantum
cosmology and complexity and entropy and
information
that i thought were all fascinating and
interesting but just in the
circles that i moved in as a
professional cosmologist and
gravitational theorist
that really didn't overlap very much
with what santa fe
did once i became interested in entropy
in the arrow of time there was a more
natural connection and so i went to a
couple of
workshops there at sfi and uh i loved it
and they at least tolerated me or
enjoyed having me there
so they invited me to be an external
professor that's basically it you know
i talked to them we interacted it all
went well that's just about it
chris dillon says how likely do you
think it is that humans will one day
develop a technology that can be used as
laplace's demon
will we ever be able to reconstruct a
historical event down to the finest
detail
uh no zero likely 0.000001
likelihood because it's gone because the
data the information that was in any
particular historical vent
some of that was in the form of photons
being radiated away into outer space
and there's no way we can catch those
photons they're moving away from us at
the speed of light
uh furthermore we can't build something
as delicate enough to measure all the
photons or atoms in
anything in any macroscopic thing in a
tiny molecule we can but
once you get to a big macroscopic scale
it's just impossible
um you don't have the resolution
literally you don't have the resolution
because
if you had used high enough energy
photons right short enough wavelength to
give you resolution on all the
microscopic locations of the particles
you would also destroy the thing you're
looking at and you would not be able to
measure the whole thing
so that is completely 100 implausible
to build or even come close to building
laplace's demon which is why it is
absolutely just a thought experiment
nothing more than that casey mahone says
you've totally persuaded me on many
philosophical ideas
but there's one i just can't side with
you on that's the principle of
sufficient reason
in my mind if there are two possible
ways for the universe to be there's got
to be some kind of explanation for why
it is one way rather than the other
could you go a bit deeper in how you
justify the existence of brute facts in
the world
um well you know i i think that the
burden of proof is on your side casey
not on my side you know you're saying
there has got to be some kind of
explanation for why the world is one way
or the other
why why does there have to be some kind
of explanation i mean i can understand
that you would be
interested in getting some kind of
explanation
but there's no logical reason why there
has to be
to be more substantive about it there's
the whole philosophical thought
experiment
of possible worlds right we think about
different possible ways the world can be
david lewis was the philosopher who was
the master of this but
it's an absolutely central idea for any
human being
possible worlds even if they don't use
that vocabulary whenever you say you
know
oh um i i
put on the wrong socks this morning
because i didn't have my coffee yet
what you're imagining in your mind is
that there's another possible world
in which you did have your coffee and
you did not put on the wrong socks right
you're comparing what actually happened
to a different possible world
and i think that as far as physics or
even physical events are concerned
it is very easy and straightforward to
imagine other possible worlds
and so what picks out this world as the
best
as the as the right one right um given
that there's more than one possible
world
the fact that we live in one rather than
the other is going to have to come down
to a brute fact
right um i could be wrong about that i
mean that's
you know trying to be logically
reasonable but that's what goes into my
mind when i think about this and
i'm not afraid of brute facts you know
these questions about why things are
eventually going to bottom out somewhere
i can't see how it could be any other
way ken wolfe says have you had any
exposure to east asian pop culture
whether it's manga anime hong kong
cinema or anything else and if so is
there anything you found particularly
memorable um not really no honestly like
i've had
the usual amount of exposure that a
typical american of my
age and socioeconomic status would have
so
certainly i grew up watching um godzilla
movies
and japanese tv shows from ultraman
to speed racer these days later in life
i've watched the
studio ghibli movies uh hong kong cinema
you know i'm married to a someone who
has a black belt in jiu jitsu so
there's a lot of jackie chan and chow
young fat movies in our rotation
um but i'm not in any sense an expert
nor is it
in any sense central to um my pop
culture diet in any way like i try to
keep my pop culture diet
somewhat eclectic and diverse and so
east asian pop culture is part of it but
it's it's not something that i'm in any
sense an expert in
tim kennedy says i was very interested
in your recent podcast with henry
farrell and the concept of
epis democracy what are your own
thoughts on
weighting voting impact with some sort
of coefficient
like contribution to budget or some
other relevant metric that might govern
how much say someone should have in the
running of things
i think that's a terrible idea sorry tim
if you like this idea i'm not sure but
it's just incredibly rife for abuse
right it's a once you say that not
everyone's vote
counts equally but rather some votes are
more important than others
someone's going to have to decide what
the importance is and the people making
those decisions guess what
they're going to wait things so that
their votes count more that's just
always going to happen so
i think it's just opening yourself up
for all sorts of abuse
in particular the idea of waiting votes
by
contribution to budget is more or less
the opposite
of what i would do we should wait the
votes for negatively
for people who have a large contribution
to the budget or we should
you know push them down to zero because
they influence the process in other ways
right
rich people have a hugely outsized
impact on the current way the government
goes to also
give them more oomph to their votes
would be just
bringing coals to newcastle as it were
um
and and besides that i think so those
are just all practical
uh considerations there's also a
philosophical consideration
what henry and i talked about is the
idea that democracy
does a better job than you might think
at solving problems like if you have a
bunch of people in a room
and they're faced with a task and they
organize themselves along different
lines whether it's an autocracy or
market system or democracy henry's point
is that a democracy is better than you
might have thought at solving problems
but it's not the point that's just a
bonus
that's not why we have democracy we have
democracy because we have the idea that
all people are created equal or should
be or should be treated as if they are
every person has a voice and has a right
to
have something to say in how the country
is run if they want to have
such a voice so that's for me the reason
why everyone gets an equal vote uh
not because i think that they're smarter
or better or contributing more or
anything like that that's not
um just not a consideration when you
decide how to count votes
jason says is the black hole information
paradox really a paradox at all
in all interpretations of quantum
mechanics spontaneous collapse theories
as i understand them are not
fundamentally information conserving
how is hawking radiation different from
any other seemingly random quantum event
um i'm i'm including this in the list of
questions even though my answer is i
have no idea
i do not know what someone who believed
in spontaneous collapse theories would
say
about hawking radiation uh i'm not
someone who
follows spontaneous collapse theories
and i'm going to i'll elaborate on that
later in the
in the ama but that that is an
absolutely interesting question which is
why i'm saying it out loud anyway
um you know a lot of people in the area
of fundamental physics particle physics
cosmology string theory gravity all
those things
are more or less implicit evoredians
even if they don't
care about the foundations of quantum
mechanics so they wouldn't necessarily
characterize themselves
in that way deep down that's what they
are not everybody
tom banks for example is a famous
counter example um
uh he i think he's basically close to an
epistemic
person when it comes to quantum
mechanics you know uh
new and improved copenhagenist in some
kind of way but most people are
basically evoredians and that's why it
makes sense to them to say
in the absence of some measurement
process evolution should be unitary
you're completely correct if you don't
think evolution should be unitary
at all even if there's not a measurement
going on
then your attitude toward the
information puzzle might be very very
different i'm not sure what it would be
that's my point so because i haven't
actually followed that stuff
i should also say one more thing which
is that
the reason why i don't know might very
well be that that's just not the kind of
thing
that advocates of spontaneous collapse
theories spend their time thinking about
you know this is one of the
things that i try to emphasize but i
think is underappreciated
which is that all of the non-averedian
approaches
to foundations of quantum mechanics
whether it's
spontaneous collapse hidden variables
epistemic theories etc
it's a community that thinks very very
hard about
non-relativistic quantum mechanics about
you know quantum mechanics circa 1930
they're not thinking about quantum field
theory quantum gravity string theory
black holes or anything like that
and there's a reason why because all of
that stuff doesn't fit in very well with
these alternative theories of quantum
mechanics
they go to great lengths to make a
theory of you know an electron in an
atom
um but making a theory of space time
itself is just very very different
thing and you have to start from scratch
in any of these theories this is part of
the motivation
for my mad dog ever ready in approach
because everetty in quantum mechanics is
the one approach
that says if you give me the hamiltonian
as we say the energy of a quantum system
everything else is supposed to be
emergent you don't need to do any more
work
in putting more ontology in or more
dynamical rules in
all of the other approaches involve
either new
elements of reality or new dynamical
rules or whatever okay
so once you have a different system you
go from a single particle to a field to
space time
you have to reinvent what all those new
rules are and in ever ready in
quantum mechanics you don't there's
something you do need to do which is to
show
where all the structure in the world
comes from why there are tables and
chairs and branches and things like that
and that's what i and others
are trying to do chris rogers says
i just bumped into a tv editor i know
who tells me he's working on a
documentary series about the universe
apparently there's an episode all about
the big bang and in part what happened
before the big bang
i asked what that could possibly mean
and he said apparently they have some
new data
that allows us to understand the
universe before the big bang i'm
english so i just nodded politely this
can't be right though can it
uh well it depends on the reference of
the word this in this sentence chris
um i'm a big believer that might very
well have been
a universe before the big bang my first
trade book called from eternity to here
outlines exactly such a theory of of my
own
um but what i bet with
pretty good credence is that they're
talking about roger penrose's conformal
cyclic cosmology
models penrose former mindscape guest
has proposed a model of cosmology where
once the universe empties out and
there's nothing but empty space
a miracle occurs and it suddenly becomes
a hot dense expanding big bang kind of
universe
and what he claims is that evaporating
black holes
in the previous universe can leave an
imprint on the cosmic microwave
background in the next universe
and furthermore he and some
collaborators believe that they've seen
these imprints of these evaporating
black holes
so what i can tell and that's probably
what they're referring to when he says
some new data that allows us to
understand the universe before the big
bang
but essentially nobody else believes
this other than penrose collaborators
there's plenty of working cosmologists
who would be very very happy
to find evidence of a pre-existing era
of the
existence of the universe in the cosmic
microwave background
none of them believe the claims that are
being made by penrose
[Music]
right i mean he's one of the world's
great mathematical physicists but he's
not
a cosmic microwave background data
analyst that is a different skill set
uh he needs to trust the people he's
working with and the other experts in
the field
don't trust them i'm not an expert in
that field either
so you know i'm just going to go with
the majority in this particular point of
view
anders hector says it'd be very
interesting to hear you describe the
principle of conservation of information
without using the word information
sure that's very easy to do i've done it
many times
principle of conservation of information
is just the idea
that the state of the universe at any
one point in time
plus the laws of physics determines the
state of the universe at
all previous times and all subsequent
times that's it
that's what the conservation is uh the
use of the word information is just a
translation
of the term the state of the universe
into something a little bit more
graspable and quantitative acac
i'm not sure if that's an acronym or
it's a cac but uh that person says
on your 70th episode of mindscape with
professor katie mack
you mentioned that you like the term
smooth tension for dark energy
i was surprised to hear that and thought
it was kind of cool because professor
edward copeland also mentioned that he
likes that term smooth tension
i'm pretty sure you were on brady
haran's youtube channel 60 symbols where
professor copeland is often featured
i have to ask did you ever get to hang
out with brady's crowd did you stay in
touch do you have any cool stories
and is there a secret smooth tension
movement in the physics community
uh yes the term smooth tension goes back
to a review article on
on dark energy and the accelerating
universe that i wrote
uh in the early 2000s where i pointed
out something that many other people
have pointed out which is that dark
energy is not a very good name for dark
energy
i mean dark matter is not a great name
for dark matter it is matter though
the dark matter um rather than being
radiation or something else okay so
that's at least somewhat uh
informative and it is dark but the more
important thing about dark matter is
that it's transparent right it's
invisible
so calling it invisible matter would
have been more accurate
but it would sound spookier so maybe
dark matter is fine
dark energy likewise it doesn't glow so
it is dark
technically speaking but again it's
invisible that's the important thing not
the fact that it is not glowing
and yes technically it's energy but
everything is energy everything has
energy matter has energy radiation has
energy so
you're just not conveying a lot of
information when you say dark energy
the important thing about dark energy
besides the fact that it's invisible
there's two important facts one is that
it is everywhere
right it is spread smoothly throughout
the universe it does not clump
into galaxies and stars so it is smooth
and the other important feature is that
it has a negative tension
sorry a negative pressure uh rather than
pushing it pulls if you had
if you had a bottle of dark energy it
would be like having springs inside the
bottle pulling on the edges pulling them
together a kind of tension
the gravitational effect of the dark
energy is to push the universe apart
but the energy itself has this negative
pressure aka tension
so i proposed half jokingly that it
would be more accurate to call it smooth
tension
okay uh i it was not ever of the
uh misguided opinion that it would catch
on other than as a half-hearted joke
it is more accurate than dark energy um
but it is but you know the labels that
we put on things in science
are not necessarily chosen for their
accuracy whichever is the first one
to stick sticks and then you're stuck
with it right quantum mechanics is not a
great name
relativity is not a great name but those
names have stuck so
yes ed uh is a friend of mine uh and he
read the article and he liked it so he's
been another proponent of smooth tension
um but i don't really hang out with
those folks they're in a different
country
brady haron uh lives very close to ed
copeland
and um all the other people who appear
on 60 symbols i'm not going to start
listing them because i'm going to leave
some out and then insult them but
it's a great youtube channel if you
haven't uh
watched it at all i always call it 60
seconds for obvious reasons but it's
called 60 symbols
and they do a great job talking about
different aspects of physics
i've talked about quantum mechanics in
the arrow of time there
randall newman says can you talk about
how you go about deciding on what
problems to solve and more importantly
what your research process is like what
tools do you use
how do you work out proofs and
experiments how do you collaborate with
others
actually let me combine this with a
question from umberto nani
who says may you please comment on how
you select an idea to pursue it to be
the matter of a paper an article
how do you decide the worthiness of
something as to decide to work on it so
both questions are about you know
deciding what problems to work on
as a scientist and then the process by
which you're doing it
uh if you want more details on this i
did again write blog posts i wrote a
series of three blog posts a few years
ago
called anatomy of a paper uh part one
part two part three where i took a paper
that i had recently written
with lottie ackerman and mark wise and i
explained where the idea came from how
we worked it out how we collaborated all
those things and so
it was a nice paper about what the
microwave background would look at
if the universe were anisotropic on
uh very large scales so if it had
accelerated during inflation for example
at different rates in different
directions that's a kind of overall
cosmic anisotropy and so we worked out
from the idea
you know what the paper would look like
and we published it so if you want some
details there it'll be longer than
the following answer um but these are
good questions because as a scientist
you know once
you've forgotten about getting your job
and getting your grant money and all
that stuff
uh you're always faced with a
fundamental issue of what to work on
and as a theoretical physicist
especially where
you don't have a giant laboratory uh you
don't have a lot of superstructure built
around you
you might think well i could work on a
different thing after every paper is
done
but of course that's not completely true
because you have areas of expertise
you have questions you have cared about
in recent times you have students and
postdocs you're
working with other collaborators you
might be working with
who have uh their own interests so
there's sort of a very natural
way to build on what you've already done
right that's the most easy thing in the
world
as a working scientist is just to do a
little bit more on what you've done
outside but otherwise the way that you
come up with a
problem there's no algorithm right i
mean there's no simple answer to that
question
you can either take a question an
issue that has existed for a while and
you're just chewing over it
right um why is the past different from
the future
or you know what happened at the big
bang or uh
how does gravity work really where does
space-time like all these big big
questions
and you can just sit and think about
them in some idealized
sense mostly it doesn't happen like that
mostly what you're doing is you're
interacting
mostly the ideas for papers come from
not sitting by yourself in your ivory
tower but from
reading other people's papers uh talking
to people one on one or
one on several going to talks that other
people
give reading papers that appear in the
archive things like that and so
you are constantly bombarded by other
people's ideas
and different scientists will have
different levels of openness
to those ideas right i mean some people
are just very focused
on their current problem and couldn't
really care less other people are you
know always
interested in digging into what other
people are working on and therefore
think of thinking about them in new ways
sometimes
people are dramatic in how they change
what they're working on you know jeffrey
west is a great example of that he was
one of the first
mindscape guests where he was originally
doing work on particle physics
supersymmetry phenomenology as we call
it
inventing new models of other particles
and when the superconducting
supercollider got canceled as we just
said
uh he said nope i don't wanna do this
particle physics stuff anymore i'm gonna
switch fields entirely
and he became a complex systems
researcher and so he now writes books on
scale
and cities and biology and things like
that so
you know there's no algorithm you have
to chase what you think is interesting
think about puzzles there's a huge
number of puzzles
out there in the universe that we don't
know the answer to the art form
is to formulate a puzzle that is
answerable
or at least progress can be made on it
in some way
um you know to talk about randall's
question about what tools what proofs
etc i'm a theorist
i use pen and paper pencil and paper i
use pens more than pencils that doesn't
mean i don't make mistakes i just means
i cross them
out these days sometimes i use the
ipad pro and an apple pencil and so it's
all scribbling down
ideas equations working them out
a lot of my physics papers are in
collaboration with
graduate students so that depends a lot
i mean very often
i have an idea because i'm i'm the old
head right i've been around for a while
i would say it'd be interesting to think
about this go off and think about it and
we try to see what
with you know conversation can we come
up with a particular angle on the
question that is
work honorable publishable you know able
to write something
there's constantly a question in the
academic community what is the least
publishable unit you know you make some
progress you learn something
is it just you know something that is
amusing to you
do you write it up but then just share
it as notes on your web page or is it
worth actually publishing as a paper
these are ongoing conversations and it's
not very clear so
um in many ways it's something you learn
by doing
right you can't actually be handed the
right answer to this you have to
actually
take things up and and decide for
yourself where it's going
dlp says is it accurate to think of
observing a quantum state as merely
becoming entangled
with that state um it's it's close but
i wouldn't put it exactly that way you
know it depends what you mean by observe
obviously okay um in the traditional
copenhagen-esque way of thinking about
things the thing doing the observing is
ultimately a person
right a conscious agent they might use
some apparatus or whatever
um but the observation itself adheres in
the act of the agent doing the observing
and that's why the word
observing made sense uh john von neumann
extended the formalism a little bit so
that not only did
small quantum systems like an electron
with a spin or something like that
have a wave function but he allowed the
apparatus
the measuring apparatus to have a wave
function also he did not allow the
observer to have a wave function though
everett was the one who really pushed
the idea that even the observer should
be part of the wave function of the
of the universe so once you get to the
average way
of thinking about things um there's no
special
role of observing you know the observer
is just another quantum system with a
lot of degrees of freedom
so we we change our focus
from the word observing to the word
decohering that's what really matters in
a variety in quantum mechanics
and decohering comes from the idea that
um there are quantum systems that are
typically microscopic but they're in
superpositions of different
possibilities
and there's also an environment that we
don't keep track of um
many many degrees of freedom particles
flying around in the air
in the photon bath in which we're all
embedded stuff like that
and so the branching of the wave
function of the universe to a never
ready and that's what matters
and that happens when decoherence occurs
and decoherence is
the tiny quantum system becoming
entangled with the environment
so in that more modern framework yes
entanglement
is completely central but it's not
entanglement with the observer
that matters it's entanglement with the
environment the observer is already
entangled with the environment so they
go along for the ride in a very trivial
way
all right two questions i'm going to
group together this which is really
really weird because you know i've
literally never had questions about this
topic before now i got two of them
they're both about what is called the
master equation so jeff
asks a priority question i'd be grateful
if you could discuss
the master equation in quantum and
classical physics without shying too
much away
from the mathematics of it and david
wright says i was reading one of stephen
weinberg's essays on quantum mechanics
and his view
on some of its remaining issues and he
mentioned that the wave equation is
actually a special case of the more
general linblad master equation
the linbladian models the time evolution
of non-equilibrium
open systems and would seem to be very
useful for dealing with processes above
the fundamental scale i'm curious why
the lindbladian is not more widely
referenced
in the scientific literature um so yeah
so there are two things going on here
there's the idea what is called the
master equation which makes it sound a
little bit more
important than it is and master
equations apply
whenever you have something that has a
probability attached to it okay so
if you have some process um whether it's
flipping a coin or
you know the state of a spin or
something like that that is being a spin
is being buffeted
by thermal fluctuations around it
and the master equation just shows you
how a certain probability distribution
evolves over time
typically a master equation is just
linear so what that means
is you start with the probability
distribution for different possible
states of the system
and you act a simple linear matrix on it
to get you the rate of change of that
probability distribution and you call
that the master equation
and it appears as jeff says both in
quantum and classical physics
the linblad equation is a specific
example of that kind of thing
but it's a little bit more general as
david said
it allows the it's an equation for the
density matrix
which is a sort of quantum mechanical
generalization of the probability
distribution of a classical system
and it's not strictly just multiplying a
matrix by the density matrix that's why
it's a slight generalization
so this is obviously a very powerful and
important idea there's plenty of
circumstances in which you have a
probability distribution
you want to ask how it evolves with time
but there's a huge huge problem
with these uh equations which is that
they often don't work
these equations the master equation the
linblad equation etc
work in very specific circumstances and
in other circumstances they just don't
work
like the schrodinger equation always
works but it only works
to the extent that you know the complete
quantum system what you're trying to do
with the master equation is to ignore
some parts of the quantum system and
focus in on some other parts
that's why you have an open system right
so you have a system here
which is not isolated from the world uh
there's other parts of the world that
could bump into it and affect it in some
way
but you're trying to say what can i say
about the evolution of this
system without specifying what the rest
of the world is doing
so you instantly see why that's
difficult right
i mean you can say here i am in my
office
making this recording of the ama what am
i going to do next what's going to
happen to me
how will i evolve and that's a perfectly
reasonable question and if the office
was a closed system
in principle i could answer it but the
office is not a closed system
someone could walk in the door the phone
could ring a meteorite could come down
and smash into the house right
many different things could happen all
of which would have a dramatic effect
on how i would evolve in the future
and none of which are sensibly modelable
in any easy way who knows whether
meteorites is going to hit the house or
not
so typically the restricted
circumstances under which the linblad
equation makes sense
is when you say well specifically even
though i don't know exactly
what the environment is doing let's just
say it's a uniform homogeneous thermal
bath
okay so there's no meteorites out there
there's just the atmosphere at some
temperature or something like that
then you can do a pretty good job but
really if you really want to get an
accurate description of what's going to
happen to my office you have to include
the possibilities that
unanticipated things are going to happen
from the outside world and that's why
you need a more general framework
lewis b says i've invented my own
interpretation of quantum mechanics
called
the one world interpretation of quantum
mechanics it's exactly the same as many
worlds except all but one world
collapses and doesn't exist
is there any material difference between
my new one world interpretation and the
copenhagen interpretation
put another way is the only difference
between copenhagen and many worlds the
claim that other worlds are real
um well you don't yet have lewis an
interpretation of quantum mechanics
sorry about that you can't just say all
but one world collapses and doesn't
exist
you have to say which worlds collapse is
it random is it random in some measure
uh who chooses and more importantly you
have to say
when the collapse happens does the
collapse happen
do collapses happen when there's a
certain physical criterion
that is reached or is it just stochastic
does it happen occasionally
so these are all different kinds of ways
that you can make something like that
happen and guess what
they've all been explored so something
like roger penrose's
attempt to interpret quantum mechanics
is a
objective collapse model where the
collapse happens when a certain physical
threshold
is reached when superpositions become
more than the planck scale or something
like that
whereas things like the grw theory are
spontaneous
collapses so again they only have one
world but there's no special threshold
that needs to be reached
for a wave function to collapse it's
just that wave functions collapse every
so often
so they're different theories right but
also most importantly none of them are
in any sense
many worlds the entire point of many
worlds
is that the schrodinger equation is
always obeyed right
the schrodinger equation says that more
than one world will come into existence
so any other theory violates the
schrodinger equation
modifies it alters it in some way that's
fine
you know if you don't want all the many
worlds then by all means invent a new
rule
where you modify the schrodinger
equation but this is physics
you got to tell me exactly what that
modification is
very very quantitatively and rigorously
and objectively until then
you don't quite have an interpretation
of quantum mechanics
rodrigo nader says do you see emergence
as a human concept or fundamental in
nature is it a consequence of our
reality being shaped
by patterns uh i think emergence is a
fundamental
thing um well i shouldn't use the word
fundamental there because often
divergence is contrasted with
fundamentality there are fundamental
parts of nature and there are emerging
parts but
emergence i think is built into the
fabric of nature
rather than just being a human concept
i think it's actually an easy mistake to
make or at least an easy confusion to
draw because
we often say that emergent phenomena are
ones where you can say something about
the phenomenon without knowing all the
microscopic details right you can say
something about
cream and coffee mixing together without
knowing everything there is to know
about the individual molecules inside
and that makes it sound like it's just a
convenience for human beings we don't
know everything so we say
whatever we can but the generic
situation if you didn't have
specific laws of physics if you had
general laws of physics that were not
embedded in a certain way in a certain
framework of locality
and microscopic interactions and things
like that
there wouldn't be anything you could say
from the low
information point of view about the
behavior of the system it would be
necessary to know all the details
sometimes that is true in nature right
some things in nature you would need to
know all the details like you don't know
when a particular volcano is going to
erupt
ahead of time just by looking at it and
knowing its macroscopic
features you would need to know all
sorts of microscopic features to predict
that
exactly and you never will but there are
other cases like the orbit of the earth
around the sun
where you don't need to know all the
microscopic features of all the
particular atoms and molecules in the
earth
you just need to know its center of mass
so it is a
feature of our laws of physics
that it allows these emergent behaviors
in ways that human beings have
observational access
to the data you need even though it's
incomplete data it's macroscopic rather
than microscopic
it's still enough to make reasonable
predictions and that's a nice feature of
the laws of nature that didn't have to
be there
okay i'm going to group two questions
together one is
from abdul abzal who says on one of your
reddit q as you mentioned that
tim maudlin came close to changing your
mind on platonism about math
i was curious to know his line of
reasoning was and did you ultimately not
change your mind in the end and then
michael edelman said
have any of your guests strongly
influenced or changed your thinking on a
particular topic as a result of the
conversation
you had so maybe this is a little bit of
a stretch uh gluing these two questions
together but the general
theme of changing my mind uh is once
again here
um for tim maudlin you know i i'm gonna
be honest here more honest than i should
be and say i don't remember specifically
what it was that tim
said because because not that i haven't
thought a lot about
um platonism about math but
since talking to tim about it i talked
to other people about it and
i there are arguments that are in my
mind and they have a certain salience
but i don't remember where they came
from
i don't remember who told me which
argument so i can't say exactly what it
was
uh in that particular conversation um
the thing that is i'm still and i'm
still up in the air about this i'm not a
platonist about math but i'm not
strongly anti-plagueiness there might be
some version of platonism that i'd be
willing to sign on to i just haven't
sort of settled
my personal beliefs about this i think
that
one of the things that gets me thinking
that you need to
take something platonistic into
consideration is the idea of
counterfactuals you know we talked
earlier on
about possible worlds and this is
something that is very important
a concept that you need to do physics or
science or anything else you talk about
other possible worlds
but if you're not platonistic if you
don't think that
math exists out there as a real thing
maybe what you want to think these are a
whole bunch of ideas that are mixed up
together but there's this human idea
that all that exists is the universe
right and and sort of that's where i
want to be that's that's my natural
happy place for me all that exists is
the universe and everything else is we
have a way of talking about it including
math
but if all that exists is the actual
universe
how can you talk about other universes
that's hard
like when you talk about other universes
you usually attribute to them the same
laws of physics and the same
mathematical structure right
but if those laws of physics and
mathematical structures don't have
independent existence from our universe
what gives you the right to do that how
do you know how to carry over
the physics and math from one universe
to another i don't think that this is a
really killer argument to be honest i
think that there are ways to justify
doing that uh but my own understanding
of it is not quite sophisticated enough
to uh really promise you that i have the
right answer where it comes to that i'm
still thinking about that
and for michael's question you know have
any guests on mindscape tim has not been
a guest on mindscape
but have any other guests change my mind
about something um you know
usually not it's not the standard thing
um
sometimes i have a guest on who's
talking about something that i knew
nothing about
right so when rachel louden is talking
about the history of world cuisine
she didn't change my mind but because i
didn't have any strong opinions about it
but i learned a lot
so that's a kind of changing your mind
um
i mean maybe joe walston who talked
about
urbanization and its relationship to the
environment was something where i
thought maybe i knew a little bit
but i was wrong and i definitely changed
my mind about that
um but other i don't think i've had any
epiphanies that really made me
uh completely changed my mind the talk
that i did with ned hall
actually um touched on these issues of
humanism and platonism and so forth and
so that is part of
the conversations that are all mixed up
in my brain about those things so maybe
that had an impact also
john smith asks a priority question uh
which
is a multi-part question but i'll grant
it this one time
um the question is what do you think of
sabine hossenfelder
she says the many world's interpretation
does not solve the measurement problem
and she finds string theory not
interesting it has made some
contributions to mathematics but even so
this would have nothing to do with
string theory
as an approach to a unified theory so i
will interpret your question as what do
i think of
these particular opinions that sabine or
beliefs or positions that sabine holds
i don't want to talk about what i think
of individual people you know sabine is
a friend of mine she blurbed one of my
books
i think she did or i blurred one of her
books i don't remember but you know um
she's a real physicist unlike some
commentators on the internet
about physics things sabine is an actual
practicing real physicist and deserves
to be listened to
we also disagree about a bunch of things
just like i disagree with lee smullen
about a bunch of things or david albert
about a bunch of things
um so she says the money world's
interpretation is not solve the
measurement problem
i disagree i i don't know exactly what
she says about it
to be honest but i've written a whole
bunch about the many world's
interpretation and why i do think it
solves the measurement problem so you
can you can certainly read that
uh she finds string theory not
interesting that's great that's
completely allowed i'm
i'm definitely one who thinks that when
it comes to unproven ideas in
theoretical physics
we should have a plurality a pluralism
of different approaches
you know diverse approaches as i talked
about in another context with musa garby
uh some time ago i believe in
intellectual diversity when it comes to
that so
some physicists think string theory is
not interesting that's great
others do think it's interesting that's
also great right
we don't know yet i think is my
particular attitude
um a lot of the debate and discussion
about something like string theory comes
down to
will it be correct you know string
theory might be correct
it might actually be that what we think
of as
electrons and neutrinos and quarks are
really little loops of vibrating string
in that case i certainly think that
string theory is interesting but we
don't know
right it might not be the case that
that's true so
it's it's just a judgment call it's not
really something that we can prove one
way or the other and
different people's judgments will differ
anders says
do we think that black holes erase
information about baryon and lepton
number
uh yes we do so if you make a black hole
out of a bunch of baryons for example
and then you let it hawking evaporate
typically we think that it will mostly
evaporate into photons
a few gravitational waves or neutrinos
in rare cases it would emit a proton
or an electron or an antiproton or an
antielectron
but when it's emitting photons those
photons have zero baryon number
and when it emits baryons which will
occasionally but rarely do
it's 50 50 we think whether it emits a
baryon or an anti-baryon
so the general thought is that
baryonylepton number are not conserved
in black hole information
which it is also thought and again we
don't know these things for sure but the
thought is
this is a generic feature of quantum
gravity not just a particular feature
of black hole evaporation but the
general feature is that gravity doesn't
know the difference
between baryons and antibaryons okay
gravity knows how much energy you have
for how much mass you have
and uh if if you believe in the basic
principles of quantum field theory
baryons and antibarions have exactly the
same mass
so they coupled to gravity in exactly
the same way so we wouldn't expect
gravity to care about whether or not it
was interacting with a baryon or a
lepton
or a baryon or an antibarion i should
say so
generically we expect gravitational
interactions do not conserve those
quantities
we have never observed it though these
are very very weak hypothetical effects
edward a morris says is it theoretically
possible to have two particles with the
exact opposite wave functions
so that they perfectly cancel each other
out and disappear like sound waves and
noise-canceling headphones
so yes and no i mean strictly speaking
the answer to that is no
because what you're doing is you're
thinking about wave functions
too literally like waves wave functions
are not
waves the difference is that every
particle doesn't have its own wave
function
right there is only one wave function
for all the sets of particles in the
universe
so you can't have the wave function of
particle 1
and the wave function of particle 2
interfere with each other
because interference happens only
between two different instances of the
same thing
but what you can have and what you might
be thinking of is two different
contributions to the wave function of
the same
particle can interfere with each other
indeed that's exactly what happens in
the double slit
experiment in the double slit experiment
you get an interference pattern
which can be thought of as one part of
the wave function of the particle
interfering with another part of the
wave function of the same
particle ron griber says what would the
plosis demon think about the three-body
problem
more directly in a deterministic
universe how should we think about
chaos and randomness that can't be
backward resolved or forward predicted
um the boss's demon has no trouble
whatsoever with the
three-body problem or the avogadro's
number of bodies
problem because laplace's demon by
construction has perfect information
about the universe
and perfect ability to calculate now as
we already discussed earlier in the ama
no real computer or person ever has that
so for real things in the universe when
you have chaotic behavior
you cannot predict exactly what's going
to happen on uh sufficiently long time
scales
but laplace's demon doesn't exist
laplace's demon is a thought experiment
with perfect information
so i think that's a distinction worth
drawing laplace's demon
is a thought experiment in principle
if you really had perfect information
all the discussion about how chaos
theory says
you can't make predictions is only in
practice in the real world
but even before we knew about chaos
theory no one in their right mind
thought you could make perfect
predictions about the future in practice
because none of us is close to being
laplace's demon so there's no sense
in which chaos etc etc overturned the
idea of laplace's demon
bill warner says i understand classical
uncertainty
there are some pairs of quantities such
as position and velocity or frequency
and phase
that are defined in such a way that the
more you know about one the less you
know about the other
but heisenberg introduced planck's
constant h
to this otherwise unremarkable
relationship and it's totally thrown me
off how am i to interpret planck's
constant in the context of uncertainty
so you've thrown together a bunch of
things that don't quite fit you say
some pairs of quantities such as
position and velocity or frequency and
phase are defined in a way that the more
you know about one
the less you know about the other but
that's not true
position and velocity are an entirely
different case
than frequency and phase in classical
mechanics
in classical mechanics there's no
uncertainty relationship
for position and velocity in classical
mechanics you can know
exactly if your laplace's demon for
example you could know
precisely the position and the velocity
of a particle
there's absolutely no reason why not
frequency and phase
are defined for waves not for particles
and to discuss the frequency of a wave
or the phase of a wave you need
more than information at a point right
you need to understand what the wave is
doing over some finite
interval and so when you have a wave
like that
then there is uncertainty between
quantities like frequency and phase
but particles don't have that
uncertainty at all in classical
mechanics
the reason why they have it in quantum
mechanics is because
particles are now waves right they are
wave functions
and the things that we call position and
velocity
are not properties of those waves they
are potentially observable quantities
and quantum mechanics famously the whole
point the whole reason why quantum
mechanics is hard
is because what is observable is not
what exists when you're not
observing it so this wave-like thing
exists the wave function
when you're not observing it but then
when you measure it when you observe it
you see either position or velocity
and there are ways of extracting
information about that wave function
that are incompatible
with each other if you get definite
information about position
you have completely destroyed
information about velocity in quantum
mechanics or
vice versa so it is purely a quantum
mechanical phenomenon that
this uncertainty principle applies to
things like electrons or quarks or so
forth
douglas albrecht says the wave function
for a single particle allows for a small
probability of a superposition of very
different positions
these distances could be further than
the speed of light would allow why is
this
any less strange or different from the
spooky action at a distance when we try
to understand
entanglement so i think you've got to
clear
some things up again once again here the
wave function for a single particle
allows for a probability of a
superposition of very different
positions
yes that is true you say these distances
could be further than the speed of light
would allow
by itself that sentence doesn't quite
make sense what what you might mean
is if you were to measure the position
of the particle then you find it is
somewhere and you know instantly that it
is not somewhere else
and that somewhere else could be the
speed further than the speed of light
away right it almost inevitably
would be in fact so you need to include
the measurement process there just
having a wave function
spread out doesn't have anything to do
with the speed of light
so the point you're trying to make is
when i observe the position of a single
particle the wave function changes
simultaneously all over the universe
and that sounds like it is uh
incompatible with special relativity
just as much as
alice and bob and entangled particles
does
so the reason why we always talk about
the entangled particles is
you're imagining a world where the
current theory of quantum mechanics
isn't necessarily the final theory right
your this whole discussion
is in the context of could we improve
quantum mechanics
to a position where these puzzles don't
occur and so if all you had were one
particle you could always imagine the
wave function was somehow
just a way of talking about your
uncertainty about it right your lack of
complete information
and you could imagine that when you
observe its position
you're learning something about the
universe you didn't know before but
you're not
changing the universe in any particular
way the particle was always located
there you just didn't know
it okay you can get away with that if
you just have one particle
if you have two particles and they're
entangled you can no longer get away
with that that's the point of the bell
inequalities john bell showed that
there's no way
to secretly have real once and for all
true information
about the spins or momenta of entangled
particles
in a way that is purely classical and
yet purely local at the same time and be
compatible with what we now know
are the experimental outcomes so you
really need that entanglement there to
get something that you would call a
puzzle
in the first place abdulrahman
al-jourbuwa
says i am wondering about your opinion
on procreation
from a moral standpoint i don't have
much of an opinion
about procreation i'm not even sure what
you're getting at whether it's like good
to procreate or bad to procreate
i think the procreation is more or less
morally neutral i don't think that that
is a
uh intrinsic good or an intrinsic bad
you know if you've been listening for a
long time you know that i am a moral
constructivist i'm not a moral
objectivist or a moral realist
so i don't think there are once and for
all rules built into
the structure of the world that tell us
what is right and what is wrong we
invent the rules okay ultimately and
there's still rules they're still there
and they still mean
a lot to us and it matters what rules we
invent but they're subjective they're
things that we construct as human beings
so it seems clear to me that some people
are going to be
very much in favor of procreating and
some people are not and that's fine as
long as they don't interfere with each
other's choices
that's completely fine um even though
that answer i just gave you
was kind of uninteresting and
un-illuminating i do
the reason why i included this question
was because i think that
there is an interesting difference well
this kind
of question i guess i should say is what
leads me one of the things that leads me
to be skeptical of utilitarianism
right utilitarian approaches to morality
try to
invent a quantity that they call the
utility the net utility
of everything that happens okay and they
say that the idea is to maximize the
utility and there are various thought
experiments that show
that if you really wanted to maximize
the utility you would
make as many people as you could you
would procreate like crazy
even if those people were miserable you
could always make enough of them that
there would be more utility
than uh otherwise and that's just very
counter to my own moral intuitions
entirely so i do think that thinking
about giving birth to new generations
uh is an important thought experiment
for moral philosophy but i don't have
any
strong opinions about whether it is
intrinsically good or bad
vladimir yoff says is the higgs field
the potential the same across space time
if it's not does that mean the masses of
particles like electrons will be
different in different parts of the
universe or changing over time
so today in the universe today
um so that is to say at a slice of space
time which we can call
space at this moment of time in some
reference frame that you pick
um the higgs field is constant
everywhere so there's a good reason to
think that it's built into the
fundamental equations it's not varying
or anything like that
so we do expect the masses of the
electrons or quarks to be the same
everywhere in the universe
however even though the potential
which is the sort of equation or the
function that sets the minimum value of
the higgs field
is constant the actual value that higgs
field
takes is not constant over time
that's because in the early universe
when there's a lot of heat and thermal
radiation and things like that
the effective potential as we call it
changes because
the higgs field is buffeted around by
all the
hot plasma interacting with it all the
time and
rather than falling down to some
non-zero value and giving mass to
particles
at very high temperatures the higgs
field sits at zero
value at the center of its potential
rather than at the brim of the mexican
hat where it usually lives
today so the higgs field is not constant
over time and indeed
the mass of the electron or the mass of
the quarks was zero
at early times now even saying that
you have to be careful because the mass
is zero
in the vacuum but you're not in the
vacuum right you're in this plasma and
so there will be plasma effects that
that can in some sense give particles
who are charged particles and effective
mass
but that's a more complicated thing to
answer your question
the higgs field value is not the same in
space time but it is the same throughout
space
josh says what are your thoughts on the
ship of ephesus
um so i think that you mean the ship of
theseus
unless there's a different ship that i
don't know about the ship of
theseus is something that i talk about
in the big picture
actually so you can read about it there
it's a thought experiment
where theseus has a ship very famous
ancient greek hero they preserve the
ship put it in dry dock as a little
memorial or whatever but then over time
different parts of the ship
kind of rot away and they have to be
replaced and eventually like every
individual piece of wood on the ship has
been replaced
by another piece of wood but it's still
in the shape that the original ship had
and so the question is is that still the
ship of theseus
like if you replaced one piece of wood
then it would still be the ship of
theseus right
but if you replace all the pieces of
wood then maybe you're thinking it's not
anymore so what's the cutoff
and i think you know yeah i think it's
an important
experiment and the reason why i think it
is is because to me
the answer is perfectly obvious which is
that the notion of continuity of
identity over time
is a macroscopic approximate emergent
notion it's not fundamental
the reason why i talk about it in the
big picture is because i'm talking about
living beings right
um people change over time too they're
the actual atoms in their body get
replaced many of them
do over time um and
they maintain more or less the same
shape but not exactly
like you know you look older 20 years
later than you look today etc
you have more memories all of those
things but there's some notion of
continuity
that notion of continuity has to do with
the pattern being described over time
rather than the specific atoms of which
you're made and i think that's
the lesson of the thought experiment of
the ship of theseus
um if you want to push it so the the
extra bonus
level of the thought experiment is well
what if they had repaired all those
uh pieces of wood in the ship but
someone had saved all the original ones
and then put together all the original
ones would that be the ship of theseus
and you can say the same thing about
people in in thought experiments like uh
derek parfit had his famous
teletransporter
thought experiment where you get into a
star trek like transporter machine but
by mistake it creates two copies of you
rather than just one which is the
original
clearly this has some relationship to
the many world's interpretation of
quantum mechanics right there's one of
me right now
if i generate a quantum random number
and branch then there'll be two of me
which one is the real one well the
answer is neither one there's no such
thing as the real one
they're both continuous in some sense
with that original pattern and we should
give up
on treating identity over time as some
fundamental feature of the universe
because it's just not
murphy says as an eternalist i know you
view all of time as equally real
i wonder if the same could be said about
all of hilbert's space is it likely that
all possible states of the universe are
equally real or is it more likely that
many of these states will never be
reached
um it's a slightly tricky question
because on the one hand i want this goes
back actually to the platonism question
on the one hand i want to say what's
real is the universe
okay and um but the universe at
different times not just the universe at
one time
so from the hilbert's base point of view
what that's saying is
what's real is a path through hilbert's
space
that is followed by the quantum state of
the universe as it evolves
so you can think about that you can be
mathy about it and you can say well
does the wave function of the universe
evolve through
almost all of hilbert's space or does it
stay confined to a small region
and the answer is actually wait for it
it stays confined
to a small region the wave function
universe never evolves
all through hilbert space if the
universe is a closed system
which i take it to be so in some sense
uh
quantum mechanics only uses a tiny part
of hilbert's space
so maybe only that part is real and the
rest is not
but that's weird because the whole
hilbert space is a much simpler
mathematical
structure than just the tiny part that
is actually used
so um i don't know is the short answer
and this is
very much in line with me not having
strong opinions about mathematical
platonism when you say is this or that
mathematical structure or physical
hypothetical structure
real or not i don't know i'm more
comfortable saying that other moments of
time are real because they're physically
really there
but parts of hilbert's space that the
universe never reaches i'm less
sure about one way or the other i mean
probably if you've forced me if you gun
against the head
i would say um we use
the idealization of hilbert space but
it's not real
there you go the parts so that we that
we don't reach should not be considered
real but i'm not
100 devoted to that opinion nicholas
weiberg says if closed
time-like curves existed what would the
experience be like to travel around one
specifically
what would happen with the thermodynamic
arrow of time so
closed time-like curves are you know
um subsets of
space-time in universes where
you can start from one point on the
closed time-like curve
locally travel forward in time along
that curve
and yet you come back to exactly the
same event in space time
the same point in space and moment of
time not just the same point in space at
a different moment of time that would be
a closed
time-like curve they probably don't
exist in the real world so that's the
simple
cheating answer you know they don't
exist but you can ask
could they possibly exist and what that
would be like so
it's almost inconceivable
that anything macroscopic could
literally travel
around a closed time-like curve you
could travel around pretty close
right you could imagine a person
starting on a closed time-like curve
going around the loop and coming back
almost to where they started
but they can't come back exactly to
where they started because their earlier
self is there
they're in the way right they haven't
left because it's the same point in
space-time
and you can't really imagine just
joining back up
uh that's not a physically realizable uh
circumstance so
maybe you can imagine a certain
individual photon
that is perfectly on a closed time like
curve but even that i wouldn't really
take seriously
so most of the time when physicists are
talking about traveling around a closed
time-like curve
they mean traveling within some set of
space-time that consists of closed
time-like curves
but not literally on the same curve and
to about the thermodynamic arrow of time
nothing weird happens
you would have to have entropy
increasing
how that's supposed to work out okay
that's a good question right like
entropy increasing is a feature of the
whole universe whereas closed time-like
curves
map different parts of time onto each
other in interesting ways so the way i
like to say it is
the reason why we have trouble with time
travel at all
is because you think according to the
laws of physics that
the past is fixed and the future you can
make choices about
right um that's the arrow of time gives
you that impression of course if you
roll a plastic demon that wouldn't be
true but you're not
okay so you think you can make choices
about the future
but the existence of a time machine or a
closed time-like curve
mixes up your individual notion of the
future
with the universe's notion of the past
and then it's hard to make sense of
these particular things
you would have to tell me exactly what
kind of scenario you meant or you had in
mind with the closed time-like curves
but
my impression was any working scenario
would have the arrow of time going on as
always
um maybe there are no working scenarios
like that that i'm not sure about
david grimes says pbs space time
recently published a video explaining
that the lack of a theory of quantum
gravity
leaves us with no real sense of what
happens to a black hole just before
hawking evaporation would dismantle it
there might not be an allowed
transition to permit the black hole to
emit a necessary final photon
with sufficient energy for it to pop and
thus such planck relics
that might have been formed in the
extreme energy densities before and
during inflation
might account for dark matter since such
relics
would have the plank mass and event
horizon spanning the planck length
is there any reasonable prospect that
we'd be able to observe them or rule out
their existence
um so yeah so the idea here in case that
wasn't sufficiently clear
my reading of it
most of the time when we think about
black holes evaporating we imagine they
evaporate
all the way they completely disappear
but we're not sure about that
it's possible that they evaporate just
down to the plank energy and they stop
so you're left with a little relic or a
little remnant now there are very good
reasons to not believe that
okay um if those relics existed
they would have a lot of entropy uh
sorry not a lot of entropy but there
would be a lot of different ways of
making them let's put it that way
and therefore they could have bad
effects in virtual
processes vineman diagrams things like
that there would be a lot of different
kinds of black holes that could do a lot
of different kinds of things to particle
physics
so it's it's a very very um it's not a
very popular theory let's put it that
way
but maybe they're there and maybe they
could be the dark matter however there's
another
puzzle which is where did all these
black holes come from so
in this scenario where black holes are
the dark matter you have to imagine
you've made
a huge number of black holes and then
they almost completely evaporated away
uh most versions there are stories of
how black holes could be
produced in the early universe and be
the dark matter
but in those stories usually the black
holes are taken to be pretty massive
right you know the size of the earth or
something like that or jupiter or
whatever
and so there's a lot of mass in each
black hole so you don't need to make as
many of them
if your black holes are only the plank
mass you need to make a huge number of
them and how do you do that that's just
very hard to imagine
finally to actually answer your question
um
as far as i know no uh it would be very
very very hard
to detect them if the dark matter is
planck mass particles with planck scale
interactions
plexial interactions are very weak
interactions they're gravitational
strength interactions
and if you think about it you know the
planck mass is 10 to the 18 times the
mass of a proton so
if the even if the density of dark
matter
is five or eight or whatever times the
total density of ordinary matter
the number density the number of
particles per cubic centimeter if there
their planck mass relics
is very low very tiny compared to the
number density of ordinary matter
so number one the chance that you would
actually run into one is much smaller
than for other theories of dark matter
where the particles are much less
massive and they're more
numerous in the universe and number two
they interact very weakly
so there they would be much harder to
detect
than an ordinary conventional weakly
interacting massive particle
doesn't say you absolutely can't but it
would be very very hard to do i know of
no way
that would be guaranteed to be able to
do it let's put it that way
justin bailey says i know that measuring
the spin of an electron is subject to
superposition that is uncertainty
are there cases where that is true of
the type of particle itself
are there cases where a particle could
be an electron or a muon
an electron or a photon so
you know kind of i wanted to say
originally no to the answer to this
question
in practice no in practice there are no
cases where a particle could be
an electron or a muon you could
try to create one you could try to
create
a wave function for the quantum fields
of the universe that was sort of half
electron and half muon
but the point is that because the mass
of the electron and the mass of the b1
are so different
the part of the wave function that was
electron would just quickly separate
itself
from the part of the of the wave
function that was a muon okay so they
would quickly distinguish
uh whether it was one or the other there
is one
um and sorry and if it's an electron or
a photon it's even worse because the
the photon is always moving the speed of
light and the electron is electrically
charged so those two particles are so
different
that there's never a case where it would
be even tempting
to think about a superposition of two
types of them
the one exception to that set of rules
is neutrinos
because neutrinos are all very light
there are three kinds of neutrinos
electron neutrinos muon neutrinos tau
neutrinos
they have different masses but they're
all low mass so they're typically all
moving close to the speed of light
and they all have the same quantum
numbers right they're all zero charge
spin one half so you might imagine
that you could create a superposition of
different kinds of neutrinos and guess
what
you do this is the whole subject of
neutrino oscillations
when you create a neutrino you create an
electron neutrino
or a muon neutrino or a tau neutrino
right that's what happens
in the particle physics process that
makes a neutrino
but there are also three different
masses of neutrinos there's the lightest
one the middleweight one and the
heavyweight one
and i have to distinguish those because
each mass state is a superposition
of the different flavors as we say
neutrinos
so the lightest neutrino is part
electron neutrino part muon and partial
nutrient
neutrino likewise for the middleweight
neutrino and likewise for the
heavyweight neutrino
so what this means is that the neutrinos
can sort of oscillate back and forth
between
different kinds if they're moving
through matter
then those oscillations happen in a
certain way that can be detected and
help you explain the solar neutrino
problem so these have been observed
in experiments neutrinos really do
oscillate and you can think of that
very much like the quantum uncertainty
in a spin or something like that
hilbert spaceman says do you have any
insight as to what motivates publish or
perish from the perspective of the
people who run universities
why are they biased towards frequent
rather than high quality publishing
yeah i mean that's a good question it's
a tough question because different
people are different
right i mean you say the people who run
universities but
there are presidents they're provosts
there are deans there are chairs
there are faculty members who are in
their department and don't have a title
but are nevertheless very influential
you know it's a whole bunch of voices
come into this game and they don't all
think in the same way
um certainly we would like to think
that what matters is the quality of the
research you do right
but guess what how do you measure what
the quality is
um you know one way is to read the
papers
right to read what people actually have
written as a
practical matter if you're the provost
so you're
overlooking the tenure cases of every
single faculty member
in your university you're not going to
read all their papers you won't even
understand them most of them are in
fields you know nothing about you have
no way of judging whether they're high
quality or not
the faculty should be able to do a
better job but as as you maybe know
in physics or biology or whatever
mathematics these are such highly
specialized fields
that it is very often difficult for even
a person in the same department to read
and pass judgment on the papers written
by somebody else
so we turn to proxies both because of
the practical
and the in principle difficulties of
this so you turn to how many citations
did the paper get
i think that that's a you know one of
the more reasonable
proxies actually for quality uh high
quality papers have a big impact lower
quality papers don't
but it's clearly not a very good one and
even
so just to be clear even if it's one of
the better ones that doesn't mean it's
very good
because obviously you can write a paper
that is
very very important and goes years
without getting any citations
i know that because steven weinberg's
paper establishing the electro week
theory
got no citations in the first several
years after it was published
and then it took off once we had reason
to believe the electro weak theory was
probably right and it became the most
highly cited paper in all of physics
so you could have made a mistake if five
years after the paper was published you
judged it on the number of its citations
um but even that's better than what a
lot of departments do which is just to
look at
the journal you published it in right if
you publish it in a
high prestige journal that is
counts better than if you publish it in
a low prestige journal
and the lowest possible filter you know
sort of the dumbest possible filter is
like you say
just how many papers are there that this
person published
i'll be very honest you know i'm on
various committees to look at prizes and
things like that and
if someone publishes too many papers in
my mind it can count against them
by too many papers i mean like there
really there are people out there who
publish
over 50 or 100 papers a year
that's like more than that's more than
one a week how do you do that well
clearly you're not
you're barely reading those papers much
less writing them and doing the research
you're part of some bigger group
that is doing a lot you're putting your
name on it maybe you're
having many papers that are very tiny
variations on each other
and so forth so there's a point of
diminishing returns but
all of this is to say that whenever you
have a situation
where many people are being evaluated um
sadly in the real world the evaluations
are not always going to be
as careful as you would like them to be
especially when they're being evaluated
at a very high level by you know the
provost the dean the
president of the university or whatever
i'm not trying to excuse it i don't
think it's a good system
um uh i i wish that there was much more
room
in academia for sitting and thinking for
five years and then publishing something
really brilliant
rather than publishing several things
every year none of which are brilliant
the obvious problem with that ambition
is
if you say okay sit and think for five
years you don't need to publish anything
99 of the people in that system are not
going to publish something brilliant at
the end they're just going to publish
nothing
so at least if you're publishing lots of
things then you're doing something
right it's a very crude very inadequate
very unsatisfying system
but it is hard to have reasonable uh
realistic systems that would be
completely different than that sherman
flips
says you mentioned coming from a working
class background when you got into
science and philosophy how did you find
people to talk with about those things
was it all people in the same education
system or did you find people elsewhere
uh well you know i was a if we're
talking about like when i was in high
school
we didn't have the internet back then i
had to you know
show my age here a little bit and
basically i didn't talk to people about
science and philosophy i was interested
in science i didn't know anything about
philosophy when i was in high school
um you know i had smart people in my
high school big public high school
um smart friends and so forth but
science wasn't one of the things we
talked about you know i was on the
debate team and
we talked a lot about um policy
questions because i was on the policy
debate team so we talked about politics
and economics and things like that
less so about uh science and when i got
to university i was surrounded by
suddenly people who did care about
science and philosophy and i talked to
them so
i didn't have any secrets to reveal to
you sorry about that
mikolaj zabo says i'm having a hard time
wrapping my head around this fundamental
principle that the laws of nature must
be reversible information must be
conserved
in our everyday life we are surrounded
mostly by irreversible phenomena even
when it comes to abstract things so
clearly not everything must be
reversible
why is it then that the state
transitions of the universe are such
that a successive state is mapped on to
exactly one prior state
so i think i'm getting a different vibe
from different parts of your question
there's no fundamental principle that
the laws of nature must be reversible
that's just not a principle that is a
fact we figure out about the laws after
we invent what the laws were
so it's not that we start from a
presupposition
that the laws of nature must be
reversible it's that we invent the best
laws we can whether you're isaac newton
or albert einstein or whatever
and lo and behold they're reversible
okay that they they just
are and so we call that a principle that
we invented after the fact in fact it
was literally
laplace who invented conservation of
information
a century after isaac newton had
invented these
rules that have this principle embedded
into them so
that principle could be wrong you know
we don't know what the fundamental laws
are
maybe they are irreversible but our best
notion our best idea today
what the fundamental laws are have the
feature that they're reversible that's
just a fact
one of those brute facts about the
universe that i think we have to accept
as i said
herb berkowitz says what did you think
then and what do you think now
of the demotion of pluto in the solar
system good so i'm glad you asked this
question because it's an example of me
changing my mind you know when that
first came up the whole demotion of
pluto thing i was on the side of the
people who said
this is just silly you know we've
already labeled pluto to be a planet
uh why are we working so hard to unlabel
it just
you know grandfather it in call it a
planet and then
invent another definition of planet that
will apply when we go to other
solar systems other stars things like
that but you know
my mind was changed by talking to people
who knew more than i did in fact
mike brown who was a guest on the
mindscape podcast back in the day
old school guest for those of you
newcomers listen to the interview with
mike brown mike is the
single person who is more responsible
than anybody for getting pluto demoted
okay pluto killer is his twitter handle
um
because he discovered all of these other
objects in the kuiper belt out there in
the outer solar system which are just as
big as pluto
very pluto-like um and there's zero
reason
to think that you should have pluto be
in one category and all these other
objects be in another category so as
mike says
look all of his
incentive was to keep pluto as a planet
and in that case he would be credited
for discovering more planets than any
other person ever
in the history of astronomy but he says
you know intuitively that doesn't make
sense these are just little rocks
out there at the edges of the solar
system they don't deserve to be planets
and neither does pluto and there is
something important
there there's a relationship and i think
this is the argument that changed my
mind from mike and from others
there is a relationship between how we
talk and how we think right
uh language is arbitrary we can invent
whatever words we
like we can invent whatever definitions
we want to for the words
but if the words we invent and the
definitions we have for them
don't map on to some feature of reality
then they don't help us think
having a definition of the word planet
that can be extended beyond our solar
system consistently
so we can say what we call a planet and
what we don't
helps us think about planets in a
careful precise way and we're entering
an era now
where we're discovering more and more
planets around other stars
so now is the time to get our house in
order to figure out what we nee
mean by planet there's really no good
definition of planet
if you just came up with one carefully
by which pluto would count so
now i'm on the side where pluto should
not count as a planet anymore
krather luca says can you explain why
bayesian reasoning is not just
inductivism with extra steps and if it
is then why do you believe it is
important to try to be a good bayesian
i think it's quite different actually i
mean bayesian reasoning can be thought
of as
what inductivism should have been all
along i i hope i'm interpreting the word
inductivism
correctly i know what induction is i
presume that inductivism means using
induction to learn more about the world
so
there's mathematical induction or
logical induction which says
if i know something is true for if i
have a whole set of things
thing one thing two thing three thing
four et cetera
if i know if a certain property is true
for thing zero the first thing and i
know that if something is true
for thing n then it is true for thing n
plus one
i can inductively demonstrate that that
thing is true for all the things right i
go from
the zero thing to first to second to
third etc that's mathematical logical
induction
zero problems with that that's just
logically completely valid
there's also sort of a more empirical
kind of induction which is you say
oh i see a swan and it is white
i see another swan and it's white oh
look i see a dozen swans they're all
white
i therefore extrapolate out into the
world and say swans are always white
okay that's a sort of more empirical
kind of induction
but that's also nonsense as as david
hume famously pointed out all we have to
do is tomorrow
see a black swan and we would change our
mind he wasn't using the swans i don't
think but other people have used that
example
um you can never be sure that tomorrow
you won't see a violation
of your rule you you don't have
certainty
in that step that you have in
mathematical induction that if something
is true for thing
n it must be true for thing n plus one
that's what you're trying to prove so
you can't assume it and therefore
and then draw a deduction from it what
you
should do instead is be a good bayesian
which means rather than saying oh i've
seen 12 white swans therefore all swans
are white
you should say well i have a theory that
all swans are white
i have another theory that some swans
are white and some are black
and i give a certain credence a priori
prior credences to these two theories
and then i observe some swans and you
know if i have a theory that says that
half of the swans in the world are white
and half are black
and they're equally distributed
uniformly through the world if i observe
12 swans in a row and they're all white
that is very strong evidence against the
50 50 theory
if the swans cluster so that all swans
in the northern hemisphere are white and
all swans in the southern hemisphere are
black
then the fact that i observe 12 white
swans in the northern hemisphere is
completely unsurprising gives me no
evidence whatsoever
so that's the right way to do it right
so it's not just inductivism it's the
other way around inductivism is a sloppy
preliminary version
of bayesianism is what i would say
harness
stark says you said something along the
lines of
in your podcast you want to let the
other person speak and give them a
platform to share their ideas and
opinions instead of you talking and
giving your opinion
however for me as a listener it is
likely that i come to your podcast
because i think you have
valid interesting opinions and often
would like to hear more about how you
judge some ideas and your opinions on
them
what do you think of bringing more of
your views into the podcast
you know this is always a balance right
this is a perfectly legitimate question
but
my attitude is you know i do want to let
my opinion be known and i try to do that
in the podcast in the conversations i
have when i disagree with somebody
usually i will say that i disagree with
them and i will even try to very quickly
give my reason why
what i don't want to do is debate back
and forth what i'm trying to do is
educate the people who are listening so
i want them to know what my opinion is
and the reasoning behind it
but really i want you to know i'm
bringing some expert someone who knows a
lot about some subject
and i want you to think about what
they're saying whether or not you or i
agree with them i want to enter into the
mind space of
thinking about what it would be like to
agree with them right to try to really
understand where they're coming from
from their point of view even with all
that
the amount of time i spend talking in
any one podcast is
smaller than the guest is spent talking
usually
but if i integrate over many many
episodes of the podcast
i do a lot more talking than any
individual guest does
so i think and especially because i have
amas and solo podcasts and things like
that
uh most people are going to hear my
opinions way more than anyone guessed on
the podcast i don't think
i don't think there's any shortage of my
opinions being put out there into the
world
and if you have you know if you ever
want to know more about my opinions
about some specific thing
here you are here's the amas this is a
great time to ask about them you know
some of my favorite questions
to answer in the amas are follow-ups to
the podcasts you know i have people on
the podcast for reasons
i think that what they say is
interesting and so you know talking
about that stuff
is uh a lot of fun to me hugh h
says if a speeding cannonball travels
further than a
wimbledon cross court winner within the
set time period given
and both balls are released at the same
moment does the speeding cannonball also
entangle with more particles than the
tennis ball
on its journey good this is a good ques
it took me a while to sort of interpret
this question
um what you mean is if a big thing and a
tiny thing
are both moving the same velocity does
the big thing entangle with more
particles than the tiny thing
um uh no roughly speaking no you know
there's probably some fuzziness around
the edges here because quantum mechanics
is hard there's a lot of approximations
we're making
but the point is when a big macroscopic
object is flying through the air
roughly speaking it's not entangling
with anything at all uh it's interacting
with things right um but it's different
you know the difference is
schroedinger's cat okay in the case of
schroedinger's cat
you have a cat that is in a
superposition of awake and asleep
and that means that the two parts of the
superposition of the cat are physically
located in different places
and therefore a photon that has you know
a location in space will hit the cat
if it's in one part of the superposition
but miss it if it's in the other one
and that's what branches the wave
function of the universe and then it
just it has two different branches one
where
the cat's awake one where the cat's
asleep but once that happens
once you're in one branch where the cat
is either awake or asleep
another photon either hits a cat or
doesn't right
in one branch forget about the other
branch in any one branch when you have a
situation
where the object has some macroscopic
coherence
a photon will either hit it or not
neither one of those interactions
hitting or not hitting is an
entanglement right entanglement means
different parts of the state of one
system become
differently interacting with different
parts of the state of the other system
so
in the case of schrodinger's cat you
have the environment with all sorts of
photons and you have the cat which is
awakened asleep and they become
correlated connected with each other in
the case of a
tennis ball or a cannonball or an awake
cat
the photons either bounce off them or
they don't there's no correlations that
are induced by that
again this is not precisely true because
the photon could be in a superposition
of being in one place or another place
and
maybe the big object has a more of a
probability to entangle with that kind
of photon
but roughly speaking once you're
classical once you're big and coherent
and in some branch of the wave function
you're not constantly entangling with
things around you that's kind of a
more special event stefan lyon
says in the biggest ideas you briefly
touch on the evolution of particles as
they squeeze past neutron degeneracy
pressure
as in a collapsing black hole and that
the collapse becomes runaway
you briefly mentioned quark stars but
past that point information
everywhere seems to dry up do we have
any conception of what happens when
quark degeneracy pressure is
surpassed so the answer is yes and yes
and no
uh do we have any conception there's no
the reason why um we don't hear much
about it is that there's no reason we
have to think that there is another step
beyond quark degeneracy pressure okay so
this what we're talking about here is um
when you have a white dwarf star
so a white dwarf is a star which is
given off it's it's radiated all of its
uh it's not all the nuclear fusion it's
gonna do
it's cooled off and shrunk and is held
up by degeneracy pressure
the electrons in the neutron star are
packed as tightly as they can be packed
but if it accretes more matter
chandrasekhar showed a long time ago
that there is an allowed transition
where the electrons
combine with protons to create neutrons
and the whole thing just becomes a
neutron star okay so there's
a neutron has a much smaller wavelength
an electron does
so if you convert all those electrons
into neutrons
plus the protons the electrons plus
protons get converted into neutrons
the whole thing is much smaller and you
get a neutron star so you might ask as
is being asked now well if you just
squeeze the neutron star what happens it
has a pressure
degeneracy pressure from those neutrons
what if you have a
gravitational force that is greater than
the degeneracy pressure
and the short answer is what we think
happens is it just collapses to a black
hole
there's not like one or more or an
infinite number of intermediate steps it
just collapses
all the way to zero um
it's easy to say that but it's hard to
prove
because you're at this interface of
quantum field theory and general
relativity right which is a place where
we don't know a lot about
plus you're into questions about quantum
field theory and particle physics
itself that we just don't know a lot
about are there
smaller things than neutrons that it
could collapse into and that's where you
get strange stars and things like that
but
the reason why the information seems to
dry up is because
as far as we know there are no steps in
between
neutron star and black hole p
walder says our bayesian and poparian
approaches to getting closer to truth
both valid or they mutually exclusive i
should have combined this one with the
inductivism question because i would say
the same thing
namely that the popparian approach to
truth is a crude approximation
to the bayesian approach to truth and
not everyone will agree with that but i
think it's right
what popper says is imagine all the
theories okay imagine all possible
hypotheses you know
he had a book entitled conjectures and
refutations so imagine all the possible
conjectures you should make about the
world
and what you should do according to
pauper is treat all of them as
potentially true
and collect data that says oh no that
one is false
so you slice away the false ones bit by
bit and you're left with the truth
that is the poparian way of reaching the
truth
so this is not what people actually do
for all sorts of reasons
mostly because just like with the
induction discussion we had before
it assumes a level of certainty or of
definitiveness that is never there
in the real world when you have a
conjecture
let's say your conjecture is uh
newtonian gravity
is correct that's your conjecture you do
an experiment and you find that you are
not agreeing with the prediction of
newtonian gravity do you throw away
newtonian gravity
well you know we did that for um
the motion of uranus you know when the
planet uranus was discovered and we
uh tracked this motion through the sky
it was not
uh agreeing with the prediction of tony
in gravity
did we falsify newtonian gravity no we
said maybe there's another planet out
beyond uranus we call it neptune and we
eventually found it
the same thing happened with mercury
right the planet mercury's motion around
the sun was not
compatible with newtonian gravity did we
falsify newtonian gravity
actually yes this time we did because
general relativity was the right theory
so the poparian falsificationist
approach as
a program for doing science uh
isn't very popular these days just
because the
the refutations part of conjectures and
refutations are never quite
as cut-and-dried as he would like to
have you believe
how do you fix it how do you improve on
that situation how do you
take into account the fact that they're
not very cut and dried
the answer is called bayesian reasoning
right you say well what is the
probability that i would get this
kind of uh experimental outcome if this
theory were true
etc so i think that you know popper is
the limit of base
where you set certain experiments
certain likelihood functions
to being zero or one but i think as a
good bayesian you should
never do that because maybe you made a
mistake in your experiment
you always have to consider the
possibility as small as it might be
that you might have made a mistake and
baze lets you do that
carlos nunez has a priority question
which is
many scientists have recently put forth
the lab leak theory
for the origin of cobit 19 as a viable
option have you updated your bayesian
priors based on this new information and
what probability do you grant this
hypothesis
vis-a-vis the zoonotic origin
alternative
um yeah i mean i've updated a little bit
but honestly i don't have strong
credences one way or the other i never
really followed the discussion
about the origin of covet 19
so it's it's completely plausible to me
that it started in you know a wet market
or whatever
completely plausible to me that it
started in a lab and leaked out and so
uh i believe what they tell me roughly
speaking i haven't really followed what
the experts are saying
again that's not a very interesting
answer to your question why am i
answering it
um i i think that this is an interesting
sociological case in how we talk about
these situations i think that uh
there are it's important to distinguish
the hypothesis
where there was a lab that was doing
work
on uh coronaviruses and they developed
one either intentionally or
unintentionally in the course of their
experiments and it leaked out okay
that's a hypothesis
there's another hypothesis is that the
coronavirus the novel coronavirus that
gives us covet 19
was intentionally developed as a
bioweapon and set free
okay these are two separate hypotheses
but they're kind of next to each other
and i think that early on this bio
terror explanation was given more
credence in certain circles
than it should have just for political
slash cultural slashed racist reasons
and it was a mistake to give too much
credence to that
because you wanted to blame somebody
okay
but now the opposite mistake is being
made
there's on some in certain circles
they're
discounting the lab creation hypothesis
because they
don't want to give credence to the
racist hypotheses okay i mean
maybe it was a bio weapon i don't even
know that as far as i know that's
plausible but i know that that idea was
leveraged for political reasons okay and
there are people now who don't want to
give credence
to those political reasons and therefore
they also discount
evidences in favor of the lab origin
hypothesis so
i have no dogs in the fight about how
the actual virus
uh was created or where it came from but
i do think that we should put aside
the political motivations for favoring
or disfavoring
one hypothesis or the other we should
take them all seriously
if you care about that if that's one of
the things you're following like i said
i'm not
really following it uh but when you do
you should do so for scientific reasons
not for political ones
scott says you've taught us that the
interaction with the higgs field is
responsible for the masses of elementary
particles
more massive particles like a muon can
decay into less massive particles like
an electron with the additional mass
converted into kinetic energy
photons etc is there anything deeper
about the higgs field interaction that
determines how these decays work
or how mass is converted into other
forms of energy so the short answer is
no
there are tiny little details but
they're very very irrelevant
at this level of analysis the reason why
what i wanted to emphasize in the answer
to this question is
mass is mass once you have it okay the
higgs field
is the mechanism responsible for giving
mass
to things like electrons and quarks w
bosons and z
bosons but once that happens the mass of
the electron is just the mass of the
electron it behaves like the mass of the
electron
and you can forget about the higgs field
at low energies
indeed you can completely forget about
the higgs field all you need to know is
what electrons do
how what their mass is how they interact
with other particles okay
um paul dirac richard feynman etc
were very very able to make calculations
in quantum electrodynamics
with electrons and their mass not ever
having heard about the higgs field
back in those days and i think that when
people hear that the higgs field gives
mass to these particles
they somehow attribute some essence of
messiness
to the higgs field uh and sometimes they
go so far as to say well you know mass
is important for energy and for gravity
and therefore does the higgs boson have
some connection to gravity
no it really doesn't the higgs field is
the mechanism responsible for giving
particles mass
and mass has a connection to gravity but
the higgs field has no connection to
gravity
because of that connection does that
make sense once you know what the masses
are that's all you need to know there's
nothing deeper about that interaction
okay let's group together three
questions here kevin walk
says wondering if you've read carlo
revelli's latest book helgoland
more specifically assuming you have or
are familiar with rebelli and his ideas
i'd like to know if and on which points
you agree or disagree with him robelli
does not seem to be as big a proponent
of the many worlds theory as you are as
far as i understand both of your
positions
anders strand westbow says in his latest
book helgoland
carlo revelli reflects on his
interpretation of quantum theory as
relations
the world should be understood as a web
of interactions and relations rather
than
objects an object does not really exist
without interacting with another object
to me this sounds like a more blurred
way of explaining the same as
entanglement and branching of the wave
function in the many worlds
interpretation
is it related in any way or is it
fundamentally different and then francis
day
says i've been reading carlo revelli's
paper on relational quantum mechanics
and wondered what your take on it is
i've heard him say
he was an average up to but not
including many worlds
so i'm guessing you are not entirely on
board so
obviously all these three questions are
about carlo rivelli and his relational
quantum mechanics which he
uh recently talked about in a popular
book called helgo land
i've not read helgo land but yes i am
familiar with carlo revelli he was the
very second
guest on the mindscape podcast uh in
fact i think he was the first person i
actually interviewed although his uh his
interview appeared second
episode number two um and we're friends
we get along we have very different
ideas about quantum mechanics i have not
read helgoland because number one
i don't read a lot of popular physics
books right i mean i read physics papers
but if i'm reading
popular level books uh it's not going to
be physics generally
i get enough of that in my day job um
and number two i don't really follow
uh his particular interpretation of
quantum mechanics i don't know a lot
about it
it's not many worlds not in the sense
that i would define it
or ever it would have defined it he does
you know try to
um he does not introduce hidden
variables or dynamical collapses
so in that case there's a family
resemblance to many worlds
he does think that you need to have some
preferred way of looking at the world
some preferred observables or something
like that and then as
the questioners say he emphasizes the
relational aspects of all these things
but so i my short answer is no i'm not
very familiar with these works or this
interpretation but the reason why i
wanted to uh
uh answer the questions is to say you
know
i don't know a lot about any other
interpretations of quantum mechanics i
know it a little bit
about the main ones enough to you know
teach them when i teach a class like
here are the basics
of bohmian mechanics or cubism or
something like that but only the very
basics and i do not
either follow the large number of
alternatives
to the main contenders nor do i get very
deeply invested in any of the others and
the reason why
is because i think that i have the right
interpretation i think that the everett
interpretation is the correct one
now as a good bayesian that doesn't mean
i'm certain that it's right
i could certainly change my mind if
evidence either
in the form of experiment or in the form
of really good arguments came my way
but i haven't heard those arguments and
therefore i have to act
like a working physicist i have to say
you know what am i going to spend my
time
thinking about i could spend time
thinking about alternatives
to everything quantum mechanics and see
whether or not i think that they're
plausible and should be pursued or i
could take
everybody in quantum mechanics as my
starting point and ask
what can i do within that right what can
i do to
relate it to the real world to use that
framework to develop
better theories of cosmology and space
time and
field theory and what have you and i
choose the latter
point of view and indeed everybody does
that
right everybody takes some either
theories or views of the world as more
or less
what they assume is correct until other
information comes in
and they move on from there right
otherwise
you're stuck in some terrible cartesian
skepticism scenario where you can't
believe anything like you don't know
anything at all and you have to start
from i don't know set theory whenever
you start to write a new paper
so i'm just explaining why even though i
write a lot about the foundations of
quantum mechanics when people
ask me about other formulations of the
foundations of quantum mechanics
i'm i'm just not an expert i really
don't follow that stuff very carefully
speaking of which the next question is
what are your thoughts on idealism as
proposed by bernardo castro
which offers a more parsimonious
explanation for reality versus the many
worlds theory
again i'm not very familiar you know i
know the i've heard of it
read a little bit about it but number
one i certainly don't think it is more
parsimonious
than many worlds remember many worlds is
not a theory that says there are many
worlds
it's a theory that says the quantum wave
function which exists in one form or
another plays some role in
every single interpretation of quantum
mechanics
uh many world says that's all that
exists the quantum wave function
and the schrodinger equation which talks
about how the wave function evolves
under some circumstances in every
interpretation of quantum mechanics
the many world says it's the only thing
that says how the
wave function evolves there are no other
modes of evolution
unlike collapse models or what have you
so in my view many worlds is absolutely
the most parsimonious explanation the
fewest equations the fewest ontological
elements
now idealism as a strategy i'm again not
very familiar with castro's specific
point of view on it
but it seems like a terrible strategy to
meet and certainly not very par
very parsimonious idealism being the
idea that rather than putting
the physical world at the center of
one's ontology or view of reality
and showing how things like minds and
thoughts and agents and experiences
all arise as part of the physical world
idealism in some sense takes the mental
world
as the primary thing mental aspects of
the world
are what lead to our views that there is
something called the physical world out
there
this seems like just a terribly bad
strategy to be like a laughably bad
strategy
uh what could be more evident than the
objective reality of the physical world
to me um i admit that when quantum
mechanics came along there was this sort
of moment of weakness
early on in the development of quantum
mechanics when the fact that quantum
theory
drew a distinction between what we
directly observed
and what really exists opened a door for
people to say well you know maybe we're
bringing reality into existence by the
way that we think about it
but now we know better right now we have
very even if it's not many worlds
we have multiple purely physical
absolutely mechanistic
theories that give you the quantum
mechanical answers whether they're
dynamical collapse theories or
hidden variable theories or many worlds
or what have you so
that temptation that moment of weakness
has passed
for most of us and the idea that we
should sort of
forget the this amazing fact that when
we
different human beings all look at the
physical world
we come up with the same rules of
behavior for it right
that individual different people do not
have different notions of the laws of
physics
to me that's more than enough to squelch
any temptation there might be
to be an idealist about the fundamental
nature of reality
stephen bernard says my question is
about the possibility of universal
principles behind complex systems
there are many examples of systems that
appear to be complex in some sense both
natural and artificial
the brain the cell evolution etc but
these systems all appear to be
suigenerous
one damn thing after another with little
or no common features at a systemic
level do you think it's possible to
discover universal principles of
complexity
um yeah i do think it is possible to do
that although the word
universal might be stretching it a
little bit i think there are common
aspects of complex systems
that appear over and over again maybe
not in absolutely every single one
but in enough of them that you can say
okay in these systems we see these
features and the opposite features
almost never appear right
you see you see features
like interactions over various scales i
want to say scale-free behavior but
that's a little bit too strong but
roughly scale-free behavior right power
law behavior for different important
elements
you see subsystems coming together to
show
emerging behavior in conglomerations of
these subsystems
you see information processing right you
see that
there are non-linear ways in which
influences from the outside world
get thought about if you want to be a
little bit poetic and then responded to
by the complex systems so i think
there's plenty of ways in which what we
think of as complex systems do
show commonalities it's not that there
is no uh
general it's not that there are no
commonalities it's that
these systems are messy they're big
macroscopic things it's like saying you
know
i've met many many people and they know
exactly
no two of them are exactly alike
therefore do you think there are no
commonalities between people
right uh no i think there's actually a
lot of commonalities between people and
there are a lot of differences
that's a that's a trivial toy version of
say the same thing i would say about
complex systems more generally joe
growinski says in regards
sorry i'm combining two two questions
here one is from joe growinski
in regards to the arrow of time if i'm
not mistaken i remember you talking
about the possibility of another arrow
of time
opposing our own that could have been
created at the big bang
if that's possible could it be possible
for there to be other arrows that point
in other directions
and andrew vernon smith says julian
barber in his book janus point
at the end of chapter 5 refers to a
paper by jennifer chen
and sean carroll that would be me and to
an unpublished idea of sean carroll
relating to
fundamental equations of a theory for
the temporal evolution of the universe
that obey the first and second laws of
thermodynamics and also have
bi-directional arrows of time in all
regions and
at all times when you compare or
contrast your ideas with those of
boltzmann feynman penrose barber or
whatever the consensus or leading
theories may currently be
so i think that neither one of these
questions got exactly right my own
uh theory that i proposed with jennifer
chen back in 2004
the idea behind our uh paper was there
there were basically two ideas and this
is always
a mistake whenever you have two ideas
you should just write two papers because
one of your ideas is either gonna get
forgotten or misunderstood because
the other idea is gonna take up all the
oxygen okay and so we made that mistake
um so the two ideas we had was number
one
a general fact about how one could go
about
explaining the arrow of time you know
the arrow of times explained in our
universe because entropy was low
near the big bang and has increased ever
since that
to me this is work to be done to show
why this is true but to me that's the
underlying
thing that gives rise to the arrow of
time in our observed universe
and the cosmological question is why
were initial conditions near the big
bang
so special so low entropy and there have
been a lot of very very
bad attempts at accounting for this up
to and including people like stephen
hawking making terrible mistakes
about trying to explain the naturalness
of the early universe
and so jennifer and i jenny chen and i
who was a student at chicago at the time
we took very seriously the idea that if
you wanted to
explain the arrow of time without
cheating
so without putting in an asymmetry by
hand
the point is that the laws of physics
show no asymmetry between the past and
future
the arrow of time does but you don't
want to explain that arrow of time
by putting in an asymmetry otherwise
you're just explaining something by
putting in the same thing right you're
begging the question
so given that our early universe had low
entropy and our late universe has high
entropy
how in the world can you explain that
without putting it in
by hand and the answer that we came up
with is you need
the conditions in the far far past and
the far far
future to be similar to each other right
that's the way
that's the only way basically that you
can imagine a dynamical origin for the
arrow of time without
cheating so if we think that our future
is going to be high
entropy the solution would be to say
that the past
was high entropy but we know that the
immediate past wasn't high entropy by
immediately we mean the last 14 billion
years
so you say that the big bang was not the
beginning of the universe
there was something before the big bang
and the temptation this is
an old idea that the big bang was not
the beginning of the universe the
temptation
when you do that is to make the big bang
the middle of the universe right
to say that there is some special moment
at the big bang
where things are symmetric about that
moment so maybe
there is a past in which there's a big
bang going in the other direction
and there's a future you know that we
live in where the big bang goes in our
direction
but that doesn't really explain the
arrow of time you're just making it
a middle condition rather than a past
condition right and so you haven't
explained why that's true
so our idea is not that there is a past
that is similar to our big bang universe
popping out of the big bang in the other
direction but rather
that our big bang universe arose out of
empty space
we know from observations that empty
space has a small cosmological constant
at least in our observable universe so
let's just take that for granted
and we pointed out using ideas from
ellen guth and eddie farhy and others
that it's possible not something we know
for sure but it's possible that
empty space is unstable to bubbling off
a little baby universe
so you can start with empty space no
arrow of time
nothing going on but time is still
passing and it's almost
it's meta stable in some sense it's
almost the highest entropy possible
state
but entropy can always increase by
creating new universes
so the two ideas to go back to the two
ideas that we had one is
you can explain why entropy is
increasing naturally
by saying that entropy can always
increase
by saying that there is a number you can
assign to the universe called the
entropy
maybe some finite number or some
regularizable infinite number
but it can always go up so if that's
true
then given any value of the entropy if
you evolve it at one moment of time
if you evolve it both forward and
backward and wait long enough
it will increase okay so that's one
idea that basically you can naturally
explain why you
see a gradient in entropy by saying
there
is no equilibrium of maximum entropy for
the universe to settle into
the other idea was this specific
implementation of that general scheme
based on the idea of baby universes and
so in our baby universe idea
it's not just that empty space would
spit off
universes toward the future and those
little baby universes would start small
in a big bang-like configuration then
grow and increase in entropy
but they would also do the same thing
toward the past
so our big bang in our in our picture is
not the center of the universe or the
middle
but it is the beginning of our little
baby universe and there are oppositely
directed
baby universes going the other way so
all of which is to say so number one for
joe's question
uh there's no possibility of arrows
pointing in our model
in directions other than toward the past
and toward the future because time only
goes in one direction right time is one
dimensional so there is only the past
and the future those are the two
sort of directions you can move in in
the time direction so
there is in the far future a whole bunch
of many many universes
uh all of which have increasing entropy
until they locally settle down to empty
space
and then in the past there's a whole
bunch of universes that grow
to the past and they locally uh increase
in entropy toward the past and then
settle down into empty space
so uh julian barber um
works in a very different context of
cosmology than i do okay he's interested
in what is called shape
dynamics which is this particular take
that he and his collaborators have on
general relativity
um and he actually heard me talk about
this stuff
at a at a conference um and
in part you know that he heard me talk
and again he
he focused on the model that i had with
the baby universes and not the general
idea
of entropy increasing because it can
always increase
and then what he discovered was in his
shape dynamics model
entropy will increase because it can
always increase okay so
he's written several papers about that
idea and he wrote this book about this
idea and you know i had to like
remind him a little bit that that we
said that in our paper first okay
and so his i i take i take it as you
know
a different example the same basic idea
it's a
it's not income it's incompatible
because it's a different physical
scenario
but it's the same spirit and so i think
it's you know you know a friendly
addition
to the set of ideas along these lines
um penrose in in
contrast in his conformal cyclic
cosmology the arrow of time always
points in the same direction which i
think is completely cheating it requires
an infinite amount of fine-tuning to
make that happen it doesn't really
explain
the arrow of time in our universe i do
think that there are
in principle other ways of explaining
the arrow of time
but they would usually involve some
principle
that told you that either at the
beginning of the universe or at the
temporal boundaries of the universe
things had to be a certain way it
wouldn't be like a robust thing
what jenny and i were aiming for was
almost any
initial conditions would lead to the
following behavior
if that's what you want as far as i know
our scenario is the only one that
purports
to do that and so it's definitely in my
mind one of the leading contenders for
explaining this kind of thing jorge
n the letter n asks a priority question
he says
any thoughts on the idea that velocity
has a probabilistic nature
meaning during a unit of time a particle
has a probability
p of moving a unit of space or not
moving at all
during a long time interval a particle
with a high p would then be seen as
having a high velocity and vice versa
for low p
an implication would be that since p has
an upper bound of one there's an upper
limit to velocity
um you know my thoughts on that idea is
i have no idea
how that would work or fit in with
modern physics you know
number one because at the classical
level right if you think about the limit
of
physical behavior in the universe that
is well described by classical mechanics
velocities don't behave probability
probabilistically
they just obey newton's laws completely
deterministically and completely
measurably
now you can say okay quantum mechanics
kicks in there right but
in quantum mechanics wave functions
don't even have
a well-defined velocity as i mentioned
earlier in the ama velocity in quantum
mechanics is an observable
feature of wave functions but it is not
a
fact a property a characteristic of
wave functions without observing them
and so it's not in quantum mechanics
that velocity has a probabilistic nature
it's just that it's not well defined for
almost
all wave functions until you measure it
okay
so if you want to take an idea like this
and make it uh into a respectable
physical theory
i'm not sure what you're going to try to
do either change quantum mechanics or
forget about quantum mechanics and go
back to some other theory
you know you're welcome to do that it's
a free country but uh
it's a lot of work to really turn an
idea like that
into enough mathematical background that
other people can
play with it and test it and ask what it
would mean for experiments and things
like that john shawning says
having previously enjoyed your talk with
jennifer roulette on the black hole
information paradox do you think
theorists will now turn their attention
elsewhere
since neda engelhardt's team has claimed
to solve it uh so yeah jennifer and i
gave a talk at the royal institution in
london you can
find online in youtube explain the black
hole information paradox but it was a
couple years ago before the modern
advances but let me be perfectly clear
neda engelhardt nor her team
has not ever neither neda nor her team
has claimed to solve the black hole
information paradox
uh we had netta on the podcast here you
can hear her very very clearly say
we have not yet finished trying to do
this they have some ideas
that might be relevant for eventually
understanding the black hole information
paradox they might lead
to a solution sooner or later um
but we're not there yet we don't have it
and so
no i do not think that the theorists are
going to turn their attention elsewhere
anytime soon there's still a lot of work
to be done there
riverside says trump has been voted out
of office partly as a result of his
covet mismanagement
and his mistrust of science which he
shares with other populists
but the deep economic inequalities that
allow populists like trump to thrive are
still there
and it seems to me that the usa cannot
hope to maintain a cohesive democracy
unless it turns itself into a more
egalitarian european style country
with a functioning social safety net and
stronger fiscal redistribution
merely safeguarding procedural democracy
which was the theme of your some of your
last podcasts would not be enough
would you agree i don't think i would
agree you know i
i would agree with a weaker version of
the statement that you made
uh i mean you're making a pretty strong
statement you say that um
the usa cannot hope to maintain to
remain a cohesive democracy
unless it turns itself into a more
egalitarian european-style country
that is a prediction that is far too
confident for me to even imagine making
you know i mean the united states
on the one hand uh has been pretty
robust for a couple of centuries now
and we've never been a european-style
egalitarian uh
welfare social welfare state right um
we're less egalitarian than most
european countries at least in in the
last hundred years
um and we've survived now that it
certainly doesn't mean that the united
states is going to continue to survive
as a cohesive democracy i would
absolutely not be surprised at this
rate if things went disastrously wrong
and
20 years from now or 50 years from now
we do not recognize the united states as
a democracy anymore i think that's a
terrible prospect worth taking very very
seriously i don't want to downplay it
but i i certainly don't have the
confidence in my own prognostication
abilities to say that unless we do this
specific thing
that will happen okay maybe it will
happen
i i am sympathetic with the idea i'm
sympathetic with the idea
that um there's too much inequality in
the united states we've all seen
the numbers of how in particular in this
particular pandemic
that we're trying to come out of uh it
is greatly increased
inequality right i mean people who were
struggling before struggled worse
during the pandemic billionaires who are
very wealthy have done better have
increased
their uh wealth and i don't think that's
right that's not how
pandemics should affect the economy of a
country but i also think that the issues
are not precisely mapped onto
income or wealth equality issues i think
that the
more important issues are one of
feeling that you have a say you know i
think that the the reason why populists
resonate is not because some people are
poor
that has something to do with it or
difficulty getting jobs or whatever
it's because people think that they're
powerless that their voice is not being
heard that the government is going
and doing its own thing in ways that
they don't have any influence over
despite the fact that it's reportedly a
democracy i think that's
actually the more important thing to be
fixed if we want to strengthen democracy
going forward
um i could be totally wrong about that
you know again
again i'm not an expert and maybe nobody
is enough of an expert to make
statements about those things with high
degrees of of confidence there
eric carstensen says priority question
do you have an ideal world where certain
historical events go differently the
ideal world i think of is where robert f
kennedy is never assassinated in 1968
and he goes on to become president
instead of richard nixon which avoids
prolonging vietnam and the watergate
scandal um short answer is no
i don't have an ideal world um
i mean there's things that i would like
to improve about the world
but and so let me be more specific there
are aspects of the world which i
unambiguously think could be improved by
changing them in certain ways
but the question of going to certain
discrete
influential historical events and
tweaking them a little bit
so as to bring about the world i would
rather see
is much more problematic that you know
there you get into chaos theory and the
difficulty of making predictions and
things like that so
maybe if robert f kennedy had not been
assassinated and nixon would not have
been
uh voted in other things would have gone
better but maybe
not you know i mean maybe you could even
say there's a 60 chance
but i don't think i could say there's a
99 chance things would have gone better
you know vietnam uh obviously was a
problem but
jfk and and lyndon johnson who were both
democrats were
you know running the vietnam war for a
long time there's no obvious
uh idea that because if kennedy had been
if robert kennedy bobby kennedy had been
elected he would have gotten us out of
vietnam
politicians are tricky they say things
and they don't end up doing them all the
time so i don't know enough about that
error to say how devoted or
how influential he would have been to
actually make that happen
and as far as watergate is concerned you
know watergate was an example of
egregious abuse of power
illegal actions on the part of the
president
but it also led to reforms of the system
you know the ability to have
special prosecutors and things like that
so maybe it would have been worse
overall if watergate had not happened uh
if i were to imagine ideal histories i
would have wanted to stop
some terrible massacres or tragedies or
genocides right like the holocaust or
various other
terrible things that happened like there
is a little bit more cut and dried to me
that if that had not happened the world
would be better
on the other hand i don't know like if
it comes to either assassinating or not
assassinating one person
i'm not what i'm not at all sure what
would need to happen to guarantee that
the holocaust would not have happened
you know you can say well kill baby
hitler that's the usual thing to say
but it's not at all obvious to me that
the social forces wouldn't have led to
something more or less similar
to what actually happened in world war
ii um i don't know maybe they wouldn't
it but i just don't know
claudio slamovitz says about amuamua the
interstellar visitor we had that we
talked about with avilo while umu's
speed was notably high for solar system
standards
26.3 kilometers per second relative to
the sun
it's still very low compared to the
speed of light would we have noticed
anything weird had a moomoo's dash been
say
a hundred or a thousand times faster is
it conceivable that a material object
can be accelerated to relevistic speeds
by a succession of pushes
from stars or other massive bodies so it
certainly would have been
much weirder if amumu is speeded in 100
or a thousand times faster so
if you think about what is going on in
our galaxy the stars
moving around and you know with respect
to each other and around the center of
the galaxy
the typical speed you should have in
mind is something like
a couple hundred kilometers per second
okay
200 kilometers per second 300 kilometers
per second something like that that's
the typical speed
that stars another object have in the
galaxy so that's the speed you expect
everything to have with respect to
everything else on average okay
this is why avi made the point that in
some sense the moo moo speed is
anomalously low
26 kilometers per second is lower than
300
kilometers per second but if it had been
3
000 kilometers per second that would be
anomalously high and that would be weird
um so yes that would be weird is it
conceivable that something could
naturally be accelerated that fast you
know
it's conceivable but it's very very
unlikely um you know
things do get pushed around by passing
by stars but it happens
slowly and gradually and every little
push is very tiny
and sometimes the pushes go in opposite
directions from each other right
so you certainly do not expect
things to be accelerated to very very
fast speeds
and i should go further than that you
certainly don't expect things to be
accelerated to relativistic speeds near
the speed of light
because once they're accelerated to the
escape velocity of the galaxy
they escape from the galaxy and they are
no longer being accelerated
by uh gravitational assists from nearby
stars and things like that so
there is an upper limit to speeds you
expect for things in our galaxy namely
the escape velocity whatever that is
fair and chris too says a priority
question
you guys are using up your priority
questions remember only once in your
life are you allowed to ask this but i'm
glad that it was a useful uh mechanism
that we came up with
so the question is i really enjoy your
interviews with daryl mori and julia
galliff
and along those lines would you consider
doing an interview with an expert on the
stock market
there may be no other endeavor with such
a rich history of formally intersecting
analytics
with the study of rational irrational
decision making
um yes thank you for giving the
suggestion you know this is a
not a good choice fair and i have to say
for your priority question because i
will always take suggestions and i will
never comment on whether i will do it
one way or the other um when you when i
try to make predictions ahead of time
or or even aspirations even goals for
either who to have or what subjects to
have
i feel like i'm locking myself into
something that may or may not happen so
i personally
like to just take all the suggestions i
can and
whenever i get a suggestion i will say
thank you i always like getting
suggestions
but that's all i will say i don't want
to say more than that i mean certainly i
can say
yes this topic area is very very
interesting
uh to talk about to think about like you
say the connection of
intersecting analytics with decision
making that's a good topic
okay i'm grouping these next two
questions one's from the new mzra who
says
if a quantum particle doesn't really
spin what's the best way to define
quantum spin and craig steven says a
while back you said that we could think
of the spin of particles
such as electrons as somewhat similar to
the spin of larger objects namely
angular momentum
thus a spin could be considered roughly
either clockwise or counterclockwise if
this is true
how are we to imagine a spin of one half
so to linear's question it is
really spin that's what i think these
days you know there is lore
if you read books on particle physics or
quantum field theory people will say
we talk about spin of elementary
particles but don't think of it as
really spin
it's just some component of angular
momentum
that is related to spin but is not
really the same and that whole discourse
sounds very weird like
if it is literally angular momentum why
isn't it spin like that
that sounds like a weird thing but what
they have in mind
is that the electron is like a little
dot right that is like a little
literally a particle of zero size
and a particle of zero size can't spin
obviously
what you could do is say well what if
we treated the electron as let's say a
solid sphere
of some non-zero size and then what you
can show
is that there is no size of the electron
that can spin at the right rate without
going faster than the speed
of light to give it the spin the angular
momentum that it actually has given the
mass that it has
but that's a little bit silly that
discourse also because the electron is
neither a little dot
nor is it a little sphere what the
electron is is the excitation of a
quantum field
right the electron field and as i
mentioned on the podcast before i think
this is what craig is getting at
um when you legitimately think of
the electron as a field fields can have
angular momentum
depending on the field configuration
even a stationary field
can have a certain amount of angular
momentum and basically
you should and can think of canon should
think of the spin of the electron
as a amount of angular momentum
contained in the electron field so that
is the best way to think about it really
is something spinning in some very real
sense um to craig's question how are we
to imagine a spin of one half
well remember the one half is a bit of a
a convention
right it's not that the spin of the
electron is one half
it's that it's one half times h bar h
bar is planck's constant
h divided by two pi okay so
h planck's constant is a universal
constant in quantum mechanics it appears
in the schrodinger equation and
elsewhere it appears so many times that
we often set it equal to one
that's why we say a spin one-half
particle what we really mean is a spin
h-bar
over two particle and if we had defined
h double bar to be h over four pi
okay then in units of h double bar the
electron speed would be one
and the spin of the photon would be two
and rather than talking about spin one
half particles versus spin one particles
we talk about
odd spin particles versus even spin
particles and so forth so
there's nothing special about or
mysterious or weird about the spin
of one half in that particular context
jeff b says
actually wait a minute i'm just
realizing now sorry craig i'm realizing
that
there's a deeper level to your question
which is probably what you had in mind
that sort of skipped
by me angular momentum
in forms other than the spin of
individual particles
does only come in integral values of
h-bar right so what i mean by that is if
you have an electron
in an atom the electron can have spin
which is angular momentum but it can
also be orbiting the atom
with a certain amount of what we call
orbital angular momentum
and unlike the spin of elementary
particles the orbital angular momentum
is only an
always an integer in units of h bar so
probably what you're asking is a more
sophisticated question that i gave you
credit for sorry about that
how can the spin of elementary particles
take on these different allowed values
that orbital angular momentum cannot
take on so that's a much more that's a
much harder question to answer and it
has to do with
um the nature of the topology of
the lorentz group okay and the the group
of rotations in three spatial dimensions
um there are relationships
between objects in three spatial
dimensions with the feature that
if i rotate them 360 degrees
they don't come back to where they
started so i'm being very vague
because it is not a physical thing if
you take like a physical thing like a
coffee cup and you rotate 360 degrees
it comes back to where you start but if
you think about
the relationship between the coffee cup
and yourself
if it comes if you rotate it without
moving your hand without
letting go of it um it will come back
only when you do a rotation of 720
degrees
two rotations of 360 degrees so
topologically the different kinds of
rotations that you need to do to get an
object back to where it started
classically only are 360 degree
rotations but quantum mechanically there
is the
possibility of having objects or
fields or whatever that only come back
to where they started when you rotate
them
twice around the circle 720 degrees
that is on the one hand what we mean by
spin one half
and it is also realized by electrons and
quarks and neutrinos and so forth
if you want more details than that uh a
tiny bit more detail
is in my youtube lecture in the biggest
ideas of the universe
i think the one called matter why in the
world is it in the one called matter
because the one called matter is really
about the spin statistics theorem and
how the fact that
particles of different spins are either
bosons that pile on top of each other
or fermions that take up space if you
want much more detail than that
then i would google around spin
statistics theorem and things like that
it is a fascinating but quite tricky and
subtle story sorry not to be
more definitive than that okay jeff
b says in your biggest ideas series you
mentioned that space and time are
different because it is not unusual for
objects
to very abruptly end in space but it
would be surprising to see an object
abruptly end in time
you went on to explain that we measure
distances in space differently
than we measure intervals in space time
but i'm not sure how this explains why
we don't see objects abruptly
end in time is it possible to paint an
intuitive picture for why objects behave
this way
um so i'm not sure if i'm going to be
able to do justice
to what you're asking it's a it's a
perfectly good question it's a very very
good question
why do we have some continuity over time
in ways that we don't have continuity
over space so for those of you who don't
know
what i was talking about in those
lectures like the desk right in front of
me
as i'm talking into this microphone here
it exists here where i'm pointing my
finger and it doesn't exist here right
next to it right there's an abrupt edge
to the desk there is no rule in physics
that says if there's a desk
at this spatial point x there's probably
more desk at spatial point
x plus delta x but there is a rule in
physics that says if there is a desk at
time
t there is probably something desk like
probably a desk in fact but at the very
least something that was created from
the pieces of the desk
at time t plus t delta t and
you know in some sense that comes down
to the
that's how the laws of physics are the
laws of physics relate
stuff at different moments of time okay
you can be a little bit more specific by
appealing to conservation laws
uh nerder's theorem says that when there
is a symmetry there's a conservation law
and so you get conservation laws
from time translation variants for
example conservation of energy
and what that means is conservation of
energy over time
there is a number you can define by
integrating the total amount of energy
at one moment of time and that stays
more or less fixed from moment to moment
take that
plus the fact that the laws of physics
are local if i poke something here
the physically observable consequences
of that poking
do not instantaneously spread throughout
the universe they travel no faster than
the speed of light
together those things imply that if you
have conserved energy and you can't
change things at rates faster than the
speed of light
that if there is something here now
there's something similar to it
the same amount of energy a moment later
okay
now you can always ask well why is there
why are there conservation laws why are
there symmetries etc
that's a deeper question but as we said
before in the podcast at some level
you're going to bottom out and you're
going to say that is because
that's how the laws of physics are
another angle on saying the same thing
would be
there's only one direction of time
there's multiple directions of space
so there is at least the possibility
that there's this continuity along the
one dimension of time
where continuity in space would have to
mean everything is just uniform
everywhere in the universe and that
really wouldn't make
quite as much sense wouldn't be as fun a
universe to live in anyway
okay johnny says is there anything from
your work that has changed how you live
your life
in other words does knowing the
intricacies of how matter works modify
the way you make choices or conduct
yourself in the world
well um i guess there's two levels to
this question one is
the detailed level of you know knowing
the standard model of particle physics
do you interact with the world
differently no not
really like it doesn't really help me uh
drive a car
or play basketball or anything like that
right
that's a far too microscopic level of
knowledge to be very helpful in the
macroscopic world
it's nice to know that energy is
conserved and momentum is conserved and
entropy increases and things like that
but
you can do pretty well in life without
knowing those things
i do think that at the deeper level or
the more metal level
um knowing and thinking carefully about
the laws of physics and the way that
nature works does affect how i think
about
life right how i think about what life
is uh
the meaning of life the morality of
different actions uh
what will happen when life ends all of
those things which are very important
things right these are important things
and they're
metaphysical questions in some sense and
to me metaphysics is extremely informed
by physics
how could it be any other way so not
that i there's a simple direct line that
i can draw
between the two sets of questions but i
certainly think that one affects the
other
in important intricate complicated ways
okay lou argyres says i don't know how
to pronounce your name sorry about that
lou
um our gyres says is there anything
interesting to say about gravitons
in the absence of a theory of quantum
gravity for instance can a graviton
escape from a black hole
uh yeah there's plenty of interesting
things to say about gravitons because we
even though we don't have a full theory
of quantum gravity
we do have two things namely we have a
good theory of classical gravity
general relativity and we have quantum
mechanics and there are very
basic robust features of what happens
when you take a classical theory and you
quantize it in some sense
so there will be gravitons if you
believe in general relativity and you
believe in quantum mechanics you should
believe in gravitons
to believe in gravitons does not mean
that you need to think you have a full
theory of quantum gravity or any full uh
complete robust understanding of what
space time even is
you know there are things called phonons
you've heard of photons right photons
are the particles of light
but we also have in addition to
classical electromagnetic waves which
you then quantize to get photons
we have classical sound waves right
there are classical waves that you're
listening to right now when you're
listening to my voice
you could ask could you quantize them
and get particle-like excitations of
sound
the answer is yes absolutely because you
don't need to know
that the sound wave is made out of some
atoms bumping into each other there's a
higher level emergent theory
of a fluid the gas in the air that
has equations that it obeys and you can
quantize those equations and show that
there are particle-like excitations in
them same thing is true with gravity no
matter what the fundamental theory is
can gravitons escape from a black hole
no because gravitons don't equal gravity
okay just like photons don't equal
electromagnetism
photons are the particle-like
excitations
of the electromagnetic field if you have
a big
classical coherent field around a charge
like a charge around of an electron
you shouldn't think of that as a set of
photons there's nothing changing it's
just some big
coulomb electromagnetic field they're
sitting there unchanging whereas a
photon
is a ripple right is a vibration that is
traveling at the speed of light
likewise black holes have gravitational
fields
that are there and we can define them
and measure them and we've seen their
effects
a graviton would be a tiny ripple
propagating at the speed of light
over and on top of that classical
background field
and since they move at the speed of
light they cannot escape from black
holes because you cannot escape from a
black hole unless you move
faster than the speed of light all right
i'm going to group two more questions
together
robert ruxin rescue says priority
question
imagine a situation where you have a
particle in superposition its wave
function says there's a fifty percent
chance of finding it in place a
and fifty percent chance of finding it a
thousand light years away in place b
my question is what's the gravitational
field going to do in this situation
say you don't measure the particle so
you don't disturb the superposition
state instead you simply observe the
gravitational field
what's the gravitational field going to
do and gregory mendel
says here's a gravity and decoherence
question you measure an electron spin in
st
louis heads you go to new york tails you
go to la
your spouse on the far side of the moon
uses a torsion balance
to measure the tidal force you produce
does the torsion balance show you're in
one location new york or la or both at
the same time uh
so in both cases here you know gravity
is a bit of a red herring in both of
these questions you could have asked
exactly the same question about
electromagnetism
right charged particles have
electromagnetic fields that are very
much like the gravitational fields of
little particles
so particles have fields around them and
when it comes to decoherence and so
forth
for many purposes you can think of the
fields
attached to particles whether they're
the electric fields for charged
particles
or the gravitational fields for
particles with energy
as part of the particle right because
they go along with it you cannot
separate an electron from its electric
field you cannot separate
a planet from its gravitational field
okay so when you say well i
observe the gravitational field of the
particle but not the particle itself
the answer is that's just as good as
measuring the particle itself
uh in this case where there's a
superposition where there's a particle
and a superposition of being at a or b
the gravitational field of the particle
is in a superposition of being around a
and around b and if you measure it
you're only going to find it near a
or near b and then you branch the wave
function of the universe
similarly for gregory's question once
you do that
you measure an electron spin and then
you move you go to new york or la
depending on the outcome
you're a big macroscopic thing okay
you're de-cohering all the time
you are not staying in a superposition
of going to new york and staying in la
okay uh you have branched the wave
function of the universe and your spouse
on the far side of the moon has branched
along with it so the answer is your
spouse
is there's two copies of your spouse
just like there's two copies of you
there's a u that goes to new york
and a spouse on that branch of the wave
function there's a u that goes to la and
a spouse on that branch of the wave
function and either one of them
if they use a torsion balance very
carefully to detect where you are
will uniquely detect where you are on
that branch of the wave function
okay moshe fader says in 2016
astronomers constantine bhatti bategan
and michael brown proposed explaining
unexpected clustering in the kuiper belt
with a hypothetical planet 9 5 to 15
times larger than the earth
in 2018 amir siraj and avilo proposed an
alternative
the existence of a primordial black hole
in the outer solar system and a method
for the new vera rubin telescope to
search for it
what prior probability distribution do
you assign to the black hole idea
so just in case you don't know moshe
michael brown was one of the first
guests on the mindscape podcast mike is
a good friend of mine at caltech so is
constantine
um and mike talked about both killing
pluto
as we talked about earlier and also um
perhaps replacing it with a real planet
out there which they call planet nine
um to me you know sure it's
possible you can always replace a planet
that is too far away to see
with a black hole that is too far away
and too small to see
that is difficult to disprove
[Music]
an idea like that but i think that the
prior probability distribution you
should assign to that is
really really small why well we know of
lots of planets and we know of lots of
planet-like things
we don't know of any tiny primordial
black holes
any right we know big black holes that
were made by collapsing stars and so
forth
but we've never seen any primordial
black holes so i put the prior on that
as pretty darn small okay i think i'm
grouping two more questions together
here anonymous says google ai researcher
francois chole
recently tweeted within 10 to 20 years
nearly every branch of science will be
for all intents and purposes
a branch of computer science is this
something you'd agree with
do you think you'll be having to use
more computer science ai for research in
the future
um oh and then dan inch says
it is fascinating how the schrodinger
equation is empirically correct and yet
still needs an interpretation
could we feed all the physics data we
have into a very powerful computer
wait until it finds the systems of
equations that can generate all the data
and then work backwards to place our
interpretation on whatever the equations
are if we could what would our extra
interpretations really be
adding so i group these two together
there's a slight connection between them
but i want to use
dan's question to answer anonymous
question
the schrodinger equation doesn't need an
interpretation at all
it's an equation it says that here is a
function and here's how the function
evolves over time okay
what we need an interpretation for is to
say
in what sense in what way does that
equation describe
reality and that question is one that
computers
even very powerful ones are not good at
answering
so a computer might very well be able to
invent the schrodinger equation but
that's not the problem i mean
schroedinger did that like on vacation
literally like he was in the alps and he
invented the schrodinger equation
no surprise that a computer would be
able to do that max tegmark who is on
the podcast is literally
generating ai programs that are trying
to do exactly that
come up with new laws of physics based
on uh curve fitting to the data
but science is enormously more than
curve fitting
okay enormously more than looking for an
equation that packages the data
in a simple and compact form we need to
understand what is going on
right that's why there's more to science
than just
fitting the data so i think that all the
issues with quantum mechanics are not
from we don't understand the schrodinger
equation
but that the uh the fact the empirical
reality of quantum measurement
doesn't seem to be described by the
schrodinger equation now
everett or many worlds says well really
it is but you're not seeing the whole
wave function and that's perfectly
legitimate
but to at least the point of view of any
one observer the schrodinger equation is
not
up to the task of describing quantum
measurement that's why you need more
than that that's why it's not just
a task for a computer and so therefore
for anonymous question
i mean it's very charming that a
computer scientist thinks that in the
future
all science will be a branch of computer
science uh but i can't agree
with that okay i do obviously agree that
uh
there will be more and more computer
work in science that's already happening
you know
you don't need to wait 10 or 20 years
that was happening 20 years ago
or or longer than that but there will
still be plenty of room
for doing something more than that uh
you know i don't even use computers that
much in my science a little bit
but my kind of science isn't going to
change that much at all
i do think that there'll be more and
more computer science like i said
artificial intelligence because
especially because we have these big
data sets and we're searching for
patterns in them so i see what the
computers are doing
the most obvious use for computers is
something kind of like
kepler right if you think about what
johannes kepler did
you had tico brahi before him who
collected a lot of data
it was the first big data era in
astronomy tycho looking at the
positions of planets on the sky okay and
kepler did the curve fitting kepler was
the one who came along and said
you know it's not circles and epicycles
it's ellipses
right and ellipses describe the motion
of planets in the solar system
but they weren't done that wasn't the
end of planetary science right because
you could say well why
why is it ellipses and that's where the
real excitement came
with newton and other people saying
there's an inverse square law of gravity
there are laws of motions that explain
why
the motion is ellipsis so the computers
would be really good at finding the
ellipses they would be terrible
at or at least it i shouldn't say they'd
be terrible i'm completely open to the
idea that someday computers will be much
better than human beings at this
but my point is there's a qualitatively
different kind of question being asked
that is much less well for computers as
they are today
when you come to explaining why the
numerical relations that we find in the
data
are there so i don't see any any need to
worry that in the next 10 to 20 years
that kind of work is going to be
outsourced to computers away from
scientists
and philosophers and so forth okay
murray dunn
says as part of a previous ama answer
you explained why the net charge of a
topologically closed universe would be
zero
but you also mentioned that the net
energy would be zero as well can you
explain
why that is the case um i can try you
know
think of a topologically closed universe
as a sphere
and there are other more complicated
topologies you could have but it's a
simple visualization right
um so if and just imagine a
two-dimensional sphere keep our lives
easy imagine the world was
two-dimensional so
the the thought experiment is put a
positive electric charge we'll do it for
electric charge first positive electric
charge on the north pole of the sphere
and say i'm
only putting that positive electric
charge on the sphere no other charges
the point is that the lines of electric
field
from that charge need to go somewhere
right they emanate away
from the electric charge if it's a
positive charge the electric field
points away from it but then they go
around the sphere
and they focus back on the south pole if
you put the charge at the north pole
so what you have at the south pole is a
bunch of electric field lines
pointing inward and then ending what
that means
is there is a negative charge there you
can define
a negative charge as the place where
electric field lines point into an end
that's what it is so that's the that's
the proof
in slightly hand wavy form for why the
net charge
of a closed universe must be zero same
exact thing happens for gravity
but replace lines of gravitational
acceleration
with lines of electric field right if i
put a mass at the top of the sphere
if there's a gravitational pull toward
the mass and i follow those lines
backward
what it means is that at the south pole
there's a gravitational push
okay which means that there needs to be
a negative amount of mass a negative
amount of energy and the net energy has
to be zero
this all comes down to uh gauss's law
and stokes's theorem in the world of
differential geometry
but i think it's pretty easy to
understand just in terms of those
pictures
josh hedgpeth says mine is a
philosophical quandary
have you ever played the lottery using a
quantum random number generator and if
not
why even if you are no more likely to
win does it still increase the fraction
of worlds where some variant of you does
win as opposed to if you just didn't
bother
it's the type of thing where you don't
play to win you played to create
um you know as i said before in my mind
even though i'm a many worlds person the
upshot
of many worlds is that for actual human
beings
in these many sets of worlds all of
their expectations and all of their
actions and all of their rules for
living life should be exactly the same
as if they lived in a truly stochastic
single world
that is the conclusion that you reach
from thinking carefully about the
philosophy of many worlds
so yes if you made a quantum random
number generator
uh to play the lottery you would if it
were a fair lottery etc
you would guarantee that on some branch
of the wave function you would win
but you would also guarantee that on
many many many many branches of the wave
function you would lose if it's a big
lottery right like powerball or whatever
and so yeah on some branch you win a
whole bunch of money on other branches
you lose a couple bucks
and so the net outcome is that the total
numbers of yourselves lose money
right because the government doesn't do
these lotteries for free they're making
money by doing these lotteries
so yeah i don't want to do that and it's
exactly the same reasoning for why i
don't want to play a single lottery in
the single world if they're if that's
what only existed
uh the expectation value is against you
there
preston says what precisely makes the
task of developing a quantum theory of
gravity so daunting or impossible
are enough people working on it
seriously how long do you predict it
will take
well there are plenty of people working
on it that's absolutely true which is
weird in some sense
uh it wasn't true in the 70s or 60s
right there were very very few people
working on quantum gravity even though
people knew both about quantum mechanics
and about gravity okay
and the difference is that in 1984
we realized there was a promising theory
of quantum gravity namely superstring
theory
um before that what people said was look
gravity is
too weak we can't get any data about it
we can't create gravitons in our
laboratory so sure
we need quantum gravity but it's just
too hard so we'll we'll not gonna
expend a lot of effort trying to do that
whereas once string theory became
popular people said well maybe
even though we don't have a lot of data
we have this very promising theory maybe
we can get lucky
and just think our way into the right
answer
uh so that may or may not be true
depending on your uh
opinions about string theory but that
that was the motivation for so much
quantum gravity uh effort going on right
now why is it hard
well you know no one ever said it should
be easy so
my individual idiosyncratic take on why
it's hard is because people keep trying
to quantize
classical theories and my takeaway from
things like black hole information and
holography
and complementarity and all the thought
experiments that have been done over the
last few decades
is quantum gravity will not arise
from quantizing a classical theory of
space-time
i'm not the only person to think this
tom banks and willie fishler are two
other physicists who really pushed this
idea i mentioned tom before because
he's uh an epistemic person when it
comes to quantum mechanics but you know
very very smart person thinking about uh
quantum gravity and field theory and
quantum mechanics
and uh he's made the point uh based on
ideas from ted jacobson and others
that we shouldn't start by quantizing
gravity we should we should do
something else and so he and i have gone
in different directions about what we do
but we uh take that as a good starting
point but very few people do
most people just start with some
classical theory and quantizing it that
that's my
uh guess it's more detailed than that i
mean the point is not just that
that strategy doesn't work because that
strategy worked pretty well for
electromagnetism and the standard model
starting with the classical theory and
quantizing it there are specific
features of gravity uh the lack of
perfect locality and things like that
the lack of a background space time to
work with
that make that conventional procedure
not work as well
how long do i predict well take i have
no idea literally no idea it could be
done five years from now
or it might not be done five hundred
years from now i really don't know
marion mark holly says at the largest
scales
is it likely that the universe has
enough complexity diversity of
structures and coupling mechanisms
for yet another higher level of
organization computation or intelligence
for lack of a better term since it would
be as different in character as our
intelligence
to molecular dynamics so this is a good
question i really really like this
question it's an important kind of thing
to think about you know is in our
everyday experience
of intelligence and consciousness we're
used to dealing with organisms
right with individuals with biological
beings and they have some very
very definite notion that this is the
individual this is the rest of the world
um could you imagine the emergence of
what you would recognize
as intelligence or agency but at a much
larger scale
so that the big thing that we were
calling intelligent
was as much bigger as us as we are to
ourselves
okay to our individual biological selves
so
i'm i'm very open to the idea that you
can do this on an
intermediate scale right like you could
have um
some super organism that was made of
let's say a billion human beings or a
billion
human being sized alien organisms or
something like that
that's fine that's a sort of on the
scales we're talking about here that's a
minor
increase in size but if you're really
thinking astrophysically
like could a galaxy attain intelligence
in some kind of way there there's a huge
problem
namely the time scales it's not the
distance scales that get in the way it's
the speed of light
that gets in the way you know it takes
tens of thousands of years
for a signal to travel from one size of
the one end of the galaxy to the other
so i haven't done this thought
experiment but if you take
you know however long it takes a neural
signal to get from our head to our feet
whatever fraction of a second that is
and compare that to our life
span of 100 years right so divide those
two numbers by each other
and then take the you know i don't know
50 000 years
it takes a light signal to go across the
galaxy and
boot that up to a certain number of
years it'll be much much longer in the
age of the universe
i think i think i'm pretty sure so the
point is that there's just not enough
time
uh forgetting about the fact that it
took
billions of years for we human beings to
evolve through natural selection
right the universe will run out of steam
before there is enough time in it for
truly astrophysically large systems to
become intelligent
uh i see no objection to it in principle
once again
but our universe is not static it's
expanding it's emptying out
um stars will stop shining in 10 to the
15 years so there is a finite amount of
time
available for complex structures to
arise and i just don't think there
is enough time for truly astrophysically
big structures to attain the level of
complexity and structure and
organization
that we would recognize as conscious
okay
slightly similar question this will be
the last question of the ama from
raphael
rusitzka and it is i thought a lot about
this one recently
if increasing entropy is a fundamental
feature of time itself
higher entropy increase equals more
configuration possibilities meaning
chaos
humans emotionally yearn for some form
of the easier more structured less
chaotic ordered life
aren't the laws of nature itself against
this emotional want and we need to
accept that everything i mean everything
we take for granted
will at some point become more
unstructured and chaotic
and will we need to develop ever more
capabilities of dealing with ever more
interdependent chaos
centers uh so this is a complicated
question it's a good question i'm glad
you asked it um it's
it's complicated in an interesting and
fun way
the first thing that i feel the need to
say is you know
entropy is increasing in the universe
but there's a long way to go
before we're anywhere close to maximum
entropy okay
even you know the sun shining our sun is
going to keep shining in a more or less
similar ways to what it's doing now for
another 5 billion years
so on the time scale of a human life
the we don't recognize any profound
difference in the total entropy of the
universe from our birthday to our death
day
okay so i don't think that you need to
worry
that we're just being surrounded by more
and more chaotic
low entropy or high entropy things
because we are not a closed system here
in the biosphere of the earth
we're an open system that is very very
far away
from thermal equilibrium once the sun
dies and we reach the heat that of the
universe that's a different story
that's a long way in the future um
but also the the i want to comment on
the presuppositions
earlier in the question you know that
humans emotionally yearn for some
form of the more ordered life i don't
think that's true
i think it's an oversimplification of
something that is true but is a bit more
complicated um you know pair bach who is
one of the
pioneers of thinking about complex
systems and self-organized criticality
and things like that
uh characterized um complex systems as
living on the edge of chaos
so this is the important thing and you
know uh benoit mandelbro would say
similar things uh stuart kaufman would
say similar things
there's a limit where everything is very
very simple
and everything is very very orderly like
a checkerboard right
chessboard where everything is literally
there's a square different color
nothing is going on except this very
very simple pattern there's another
limit
where things are just completely random
where rather than a checkerboard where
if you're on a black square you know
that all the squares around you are
white
if you move in you know vertical and or
horizontal directions
if you're on a completely random board
then knowing what the color of one
square is tells you nothing
about the squares next to it neither one
of those limits
is interesting in the sense of
biological organization
where you have interestingness is in
between that's the edge of chaos
so you have some structure but not
perfect rigidity
okay and we are not just not
not only do human beings feature
that kind of in-between level of
structure
but we live off the fact that the earth
is very far from thermal equilibrium
right that's what lets us maintain this
very far from uh perfectly ordered or
perfectly chaotic
in between state so like i say in many
different talks in many different
contexts
the second law of thermodynamics and the
increase of entropy
is not our enemy as living breathing
beings it's our friend
it enables us to live and to breathe it
gives us a resource
that we depend on and survive because of
and we have again another several
billion years worth of it just because
the sun is shining a hot spot in the
dark
sky so uh life is much more interesting
and intricate
than just avoiding chaos or something
like that
life is about having a little bit of
chaos but not too much which is a lot
more fun
a lot more challenging but a lot more
rewarding way to live
and with that pseudo-profound thought uh
that's the end of the ama for this month
thank you to all the patreon supporters
for supporting mindscape i really
appreciate it and to everyone thanks for
listening i appreciate that
too take care bye
[Music]
you